So, heute bin ich noch nicht so lange wach, erst so eine Stunde ungefähr, wirklich wach bin ich aber auch noch nicht, ich bin aus dem Bett raus, wach ist vielleicht der falsche Ausdruck dafür, alles klar, so, ich bin früh, ja, naja, ich bin, was heißt früh, ich bin 15 Minuten früher als sonst,
also, das macht es jetzt ja auch nicht fett, hat irgendjemand von euch was gekauft beim Prime Day, ich hatte ja mal kurz geguckt und einen Tag später auch, es war eigentlich wieder, es sei denn, man möchte Amazon Geräte haben, das ist immer ganz gut, ja, aber es war wieder alles wahnsinnig sinnlos, es gab ein paar gescheite Sachen, es gab mal wieder ein paar gute SSDs, relativ günstig,
aber, ich meine, ich sage zwar immer, SSDs kann man nicht genug haben,
aber ich habe genug SSDs mittlerweile, also, ich brauche erstmal keine SSDs, einzige SSD, die ich vielleicht brauchen könnte, wäre noch eine zweite 2TB M2 oder so, für das NAS, aber das brauche ich auch nicht wirklich, also, Prime Day war komplett sinnlos, für mich,
generell, ich glaube, also, was heißt, ne, glaube ich nicht, ist für meinen Geschmack, muss ich so sagen, wäre es mir lieber, Amazon würde nicht 80, 180.000 Sachen anbieten am Prime Day, sondern vielleicht bloß 10.000 Sachen und davon ab und zu halt mal was Gescheites, das wäre mir lieber, aber Amazon wird schon wissen, was sie machen, also, ich denke mal, keiner kann so gut Leute dazu bringen, was zu kaufen, wie Amazon,
die sind nicht umsonst so groß geworden, die Amazon-Suche kann es ja nicht sein, die dazu führt, dass man das findet, was man braucht, weil die Amazon-Suche findet oftmals nicht das, was man eigentlich gesucht hat, obwohl Amazon das hat, aber der Amazon-Empfehlungs-Algorithmus scheint so gut zu funktionieren, dass die Leute was kaufen, was sie brauchen, aber noch gar nicht wussten, dass sie es brauchen,
das sind Staubsauger-Roboter, oder was ist das?
vom Namen her würde ich vermuten, dass es ein Staubsauger-Roboter,
ja, das haben auch ein paar Leute vor ein paar Tagen im Chat geschrieben, dass das wohl irgendwie taugen soll,
aha, ja, das Tolle ist ja, so die zweite Jahreshälfte, die ist ja voll von diesen Sales, es gibt jetzt irgendwie Cyber Monday, dann gibt es Black Friday, dann gibt es Black Friday Week, ich warte noch drauf, dass die Leute Black Friday Monat oder Black Friday Quartal,
bald haben wir ein ganzes Black Friday Monat.
friday hier haben das kommt jetzt ja alles wieder mal ganz davon abgesehen
die tun ja immer so wenn man bei ihnen jetzt was kauft hat man am ende mehr
geld als vorher die schwachsinn ist aber es hört sich in der werbung und wenn du
dir das zeug bei amazon anguckt immer so an so nach dem motto 400 euro und jetzt
kannst du für 120 euro bekommen normalerweise verkauft hat auch keiner
von 400 euro die preise die amazon drauf schreibt und durchstreicht sind ja
komplett random also hat mit der realität nichts zu tun
aber trotzdem ich mein wenn man es braucht oder wenn man amazon geräte
braucht ist doch ist es okay vielleicht auch für das eine oder andere aber wie
gesagt mir wäre es lieber die würden da nicht tausende hunderttausende
verschiedene sachen anbieten sondern vielleicht ein bisschen weniger und dann
halt ab und zu mal was was ihnen wirklich gut ist oder sagen wir so die
würden das behalten was ganz
gutes und einfach die 90 prozent kraft
rausschmeißen was machen eigentlich gerade die
versandzeiten auf aliexpress ich wusste es muss das mal kurz kurz checken
netflix account deutsch moment warum sollte ich mir einen netflix
account auf amazon auf auf aliexpress kaufen der kunde was ist das sieht aus
aus wie eine Maus, ist aber keine Maus.
Okay, man versteht's
nicht. So, lass mal kurz,
ich muss mal kurz checken,
wie denn so
die Versand...
Ja, ja, das ist ja alles Blödsinn, was hier steht,
ja. Also, wie ist denn so
die Versanddauer mittlerweile bei AliExpress?
12. August, ja gut,
das kommt aus Polen, okay.
China...
Also,
AliExpress
möchte uns wirklich erzählen,
die Lieferung aus China
ist günstiger
und schneller
als aus Polen,
ja.
Weiß nicht.
Vielleicht, wisst ihr was,
ich mein, theoretisch, theoretisch
kann das sein. Vielleicht haben die
gerade ein Schiff auf dem Weg und
noch nicht alles, was in Containern drin ist,
ist überhaupt verkauft.
Also, ich
trau das denen schon zu.
Allerdings muss man sagen, 10. August
ist halt ganz schön...
lang. Und 12. August
aus Polen ist auch
ganz schön lang.
Aus Polen würde ich erwarten, das kommt
am 20. oder so.
Also, irgendwie
nicht so der Wahnsinn, ja.
Was? Was soll mir
dieses Display sagen?
Da werden bestimmt nicht drei Microcontroller drauf sein.
Doch.
Wait a minute, was?
Jetzt splege ich nicht mehr durch.
Ähm, ja, ist ja aber auch,
so, ist ganz schön, dauert
ganz schön lange, der Versand, mittlerweile.
Wie sieht's eigentlich mit den
Schiffen in Shanghai aus?
Dürfen die Schiffe in Shanghai
wieder rein und raus?
Ich hab das jetzt, ich hab das jetzt schon eine ganze Weile
nix mehr, nix mehr vor mitbekommen.
Schau mal.
Shanghai AliExpress.
News. Gibt's da was?
Hä?
Schiffe, Schiffe.
Schiffe.
Lieferketten-Problem noch länger gestört.
Ja, das, äh, da war vorauszugehen, ja.
Hast du?
Was ist denn ein Fake-ESP
866? Ich mein,
der ESP 8266
ist doch schon China-Chinesen-Kram.
Faken die Chinesen jetzt schon China-Kram?
Oder?
Oder was ist da los?
Ch-Chinesen-China-Fake.
Das ist ja, das ist ja
auf ganz neuem Level dann.
Ganz einfach, vielleicht geht der Container ja an
irgendein EU-Waren-Container.
Und von da weiter.
Und die liefern da halt mehr hin,
weil der Container noch nicht voll war mit den Bestellungen.
Und die faken wirklich,
also, die AliExpress-Chinesen
faken China-
China-Hardware.
Also, Chinesen faken China-Hardware.
Das jetzt, jetzt ist aber
vorbei irgendwann, ne?
Da blickst du,
die sind ja, die haben ja vor gar nix mehr
halt.
Ich dachte, wenigstens ihr eigenes Zeug,
ich würde sie nicht faken.
Aber ihr eigenes Zeug ist wahrscheinlich zu gut
mittlerweile, dass man es
auch, dass es schon fakebar geworden ist.
Ja, ich hab irgendwo
einen Amazon-Link, aber das lohnt sich nicht.
Ähm, also,
du kriegst ja dann nicht Prozente, du kriegst es gecappt
auf irgendwie 10 Euro pro Stück oder so
maximal. Also,
kauf einfach. Ich hab irgendwo
einen, aber es ist jetzt nicht so.
Brauch ich nicht. Aber schön, dass du dran denkst.
Silvercross, danke schön für den Sub.
Der China-Chinesen-China-Fake ist das.
Ja, echt so.
Wahnsinn.
Ja, das ist gecappt.
Also, es gab mal
so 2012 rum
oder so, hatte Amazon ein richtig cooles
Affiliate-Programm. Da hast du
prozentual bekommen
und je nachdem, wie viel du verkauft
hast, hast du dann mehr Prozente bekommen.
Was ganz nice war.
Weil es dir auch geholfen hat, wenn die Leute viel
Kleinscheiß gekauft haben.
Nee, nee, 10% hast du damals auch
nicht gekriegt, aber
das ging dann, das ging, glaube ich, rauf, bis auf
ja, nicht mehr,
5, 6% oder so.
Aber da musstest du wirklich viel, viel,
viel
verkaufen. So viel hatte ich nie.
Das ist eher was für Leute, die halt ganz viel Kleinkram
verkauft haben über ihr Affiliate-Zeug.
Da musstest du wirklich viel verkaufen.
Bei mir war das nicht so.
Aber trotzdem, du hast halt prozentual gekriegt.
Das war damals, glaube ich, auch noch nicht
so klein gecappt.
Mittlerweile ist es, glaube ich, bei 10 Euro
oder irgendwie sowas.
Was du kriegst pro Teil.
Dass du 10 Euro kriegst, muss es ja schon mal
was richtig Fettes sein.
Was du verkaufst, also was richtig Teures.
Von einem Wecker
oder was auch immer, kriegst du keine 10 Euro.
Kostet ja nur, selbst kostet ja nur
10 Euro.
Da kriegst du, kriegst du 20 Cent
oder so. Aber immerhin.
Also Amazon, Amazon
Affiliate
ist halt insofern ganz praktisch.
Es kostet dich
nix. Es kostet,
den Käufern nix.
Es kostet wahrscheinlich doch nicht mal Bezos was.
Weil die ja an dem Zeug, was sie verkaufen,
verdienen. Also insofern ist das
eigentlich ganz gut.
Das kannst du passiv einfach
mitmachen und wer Amazon bestellt,
hat dadurch keine Nachteile und du kriegst ein bisschen was.
Also insofern ist Amazon Affiliate
eigentlich das einfachste, was man machen kann.
Wo ich gerade erzähle,
das einfachste, was man machen kann. Mach ich denn überhaupt
Amazon Affiliate gerade?
Glaube, mach ich gar nicht, oder?
Nö.
Also, ja, es ist das Einfachste, was man machen kann, aber nicht mal das mache ich.
Na toll.
Also, ich bin einfach kein
Stonksverdiener, was das angeht.
Nee, du musst das gar nicht selbst machen.
Du dropshippst das einfach aus China.
Das.
Du dropshippst den Wecker einfach aus China.
New Games just don't feel
this cinematic anymore.
Das ist Battlefield 4 mit dem Schiff, ne?
Das war tatsächlich wirklich cool.
Ich weiß aber gar nicht mal unter welcher Bedingung
das überhaupt gestrandet ist, das Schiff.
Das ging ja auch nicht.
Das ging ja auch nicht jede Runde.
Ja, Hetzner ist gerade noch...
Ich wollte ja eigentlich dieses Wochenende streamen,
aber wir sind noch nicht ganz fertig mit den...
Ja, was wir genau machen.
Und ich hab schon einen Code,
aber den gibt's noch nicht offiziell.
Ja, diese Primitive...
Diese Primitive Building Videos ist auch so
der nächste indische Scam.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob ihr diese Videos auch manchmal empfohlen bekommt.
Da hast du dann irgendwelche Leute im Dschungel,
die bauen dann irgendwie unterirdischen Swimmingpool.
Angeblich irgendwie 1-2 Leute.
Und...
Das ist dann so richtig advanced
mit Verzierung an der Wand und sonst was.
Und keiner überlegt sich ja,
wie haben die das Wasser da reinbekommen?
Warum ist das so klar? Und sonst wie?
Und...
Naja.
Also, die Dinger, finde ich,
sind so offensichtlich fake.
Ich weiß gar nicht,
warum es jetzt wohl so lange gedauert hat,
bis anscheinend mal einer feststellt,
dass die fake sind.
Ja.
Und dahinter steht wahrscheinlich der Bagger.
Wenn man bei manchen Videos richtig guckt,
sieht man sogar LKWs drinne stehen.
Im Hintergrund.
Also, die sind...
Das ist einfach richtig...
Egal.
Es gibt...
Der einzig gute Channel in der Richtung ist
Primitive Technology.
Ja, das Original.
Ja.
Das Original.
Der Dude.
Alter.
Das ist der einzige Channel,
der was taugt in der Richtung.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Wie gesagt, würde mich nicht wundern.
Also, LKWs habe ich schon gesehen in den Videos.
Bagger noch nicht.
Aber es ist auch definitiv nicht von einem gebaut,
wie es in diesen Videos immer ist.
Das ist totaler Schwachsinn.
Das ist einfach nur fake as fuck.
So, ich refreshe mal noch ein bisschen.
Wer weiß.
Vielleicht kommt noch irgendwas Gescheites.
Ansonsten gucken wir uns gleich eine Runde Level Capture Bayland an.
Oh, Mann.
Ja, stimmt.
Alter.
Das war im Ernst.
Ich kann diese Aufregung und diese ganze Schlagergeschichte nicht verstehen.
Also...
Ich meine, der Text ist sicherlich keine Ausgeburt des lyrischen Genies.
Aber...
Also, wenn du das verbietest,
müsstest du wahrscheinlich auch 90% von Deutschrap verbieten.
Aber ganz davon abgesehen,
ich glaube, das Beste, was diesem Typ...
der sich das ausgedacht hat, passieren konnte,
ist, dass das verboten wird.
Der Typ hätte doch nie so viel Werbung
und so viel Bekanntheit erlangt,
wäre das nicht verboten worden.
Ich könnte mir fast schon vorstellen, dass das Absicht gewesen ist.
Okay, verboten ist es nicht.
Das ist richtig.
Manche Läden haben gesagt, sie wollen es nicht mehr spielen.
Ich kann es nicht verstehen,
dass da überhaupt so eine Riesenaufregung drum ist.
Ich meine, es ist halt dummer Text.
Aber was erwarte ich bei so 0815 Schlager?
Ich meine, die haben alle dumme Texte.
Das ist jetzt halt ein bisschen...
ja, nicht nur dummer Text,
sondern auch noch ein bisschen unter der Gürtellinie Text.
Aber ich meine,
wie juckt es?
Warum juckt es so viele Leute überhaupt?
Das ist beste Promo, die es gibt.
Ja, ist echt so.
Es gibt deutlich Schlimmeres,
was auch niemand juckt.
Ich meine, man wird bei allem irgendwas finden,
was schlimmer ist.
Aber trotzdem, in dem Fall,
ich verstehe nicht, warum so viele Leute juckt.
Keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich, dass man einfach mal wieder...
Ah, ja, ja, ja.
Was hat, über das man sich empören kann?
Das ist ja eh das neueste Hobby,
dass sich alle empören.
Und dann gehen sie auf Twitter
und dann wird dann sich empört mit anderen Empörten.
Und dann ist man ganz furchtbar empört ein paar Tage lang.
Und dann kommt das nächste Thema,
über was man empört ist.
Sommerloch?
Ey, immer.
Dauer, dauerhaft.
Empörung ist mittlerweile
zweites Hobby von vielen Leuten.
Sobald irgendwas ist,
wird überall sich wahnsinnig...
Wahnsinnig empört.
Und besonders auf Twitter
ist es ganz, ganz besonders ätzend.
So, dann würde ich sagen,
lassen wir uns mal eine Runde
Level Cap G-Baden.
Was hat er denn?
Alter.
Okay, schau wieder.
Okay, ich predikte mal wieder
das Level Cap Video.
Er erzählt uns jetzt,
dass huge changes kommen.
Huge changes kommen
für Battlefield 2042.
Das, was er uns quasi jede Woche im Video erzählt.
Huge changes und
und, und, und,
irgendwie ganz furchtbar spannende neue Sachen kommen da.
Und am Ende des Videos fragt er uns dann...
Ah, ne, der Reality Mod ist diesmal angesagt.
Okay.
Ja, da bin ich gespannt.
Heute Abend 20 Uhr kann man das spielen.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass mir der Reality Mod
großartig Spaß machen wird, weil
was ich an Battlefield 3 gut fand,
fand, war Battlefield 3.
Und Battlefield 3 auf, auf, auf Squad gemacht.
Weiß ich nicht, ob mir das gefällt.
Naja, zumindest wird er uns dann am Ende fragen.
Und denkt ihr jetzt, dass Battlefield 2042 in einem besseren Spot ist?
Das fragt er jedes Mal.
Die Videos sind wirklich immer,
immer das gleiche.
Major changes, genau.
Okay, gucken wir uns das mal an.
Lass uns mal eine Runde Level Capture Baden. Auf geht's.
Portal might be getting Battlefield 5 content soon.
Modern Warfare 2 suffered another massive data leak.
A new single player...
Also bei Modern Warfare muss ich euch ganz ehrlich sagen,
ich glaube mittlerweile, generell schon die letzten Jahre über,
bei Call of Duty nicht mehr an irgendwelche Leaks.
Weil wer soll die denn da irgendwie machen?
Und was soll die denn da irgendwie zufällig finden?
Es ist ja nicht so, als hätten die da irgendwie einen ungeschützten Webserver
und irgendwie der krasse Hackerman hat das gefunden
und hat das dann abgezogen und dann wurde das geleakt.
Und dann, oh, guck mal da.
Und der Hersteller sagt, nein, das wollten wir überhaupt nicht,
dass das rauskommt.
Diese Leaks kommen immer zu so günstigen Zeitpunkten,
in so günstigen Häppchen,
dass ich seit Jahren schon davon ausgehe,
dass ein Großteil dieser Leaks schlicht und ergreifend
als Leak getarntes Marketing ist.
...Aliens Game is coming and much more on this week in gaming.
Dataminer Temporel has uncovered Battlefield 5 Content
hidden in 2042's Game Files.
According to him, the AEK, AUG, Bren, RPK, SKS, M2 Carbine, M95 and M249 are all...
Ist das nicht...
Ist das nicht Battlefield 3 und Battlefield 4 Content?
Ja, EK.
Ist Battlefield 3 und 4, die AUG, ist Battlefield...
äh...
Gute Frage.
Gab's die...
Die AUG gab's in Battlefield 3, ja.
Die Bren, das ist...
Das ist...
Das ist BF1.
Ne, BF5, oder?
Ist...
Ist BF5.
PK ist, ähm...
BC2 und BF3 und wahrscheinlich auch BF4.
Das ist BF3.
Das ist, ähm...
Wahrscheinlich Battlefield 5.
M95 ist BC2 und, äh...
BF4.
Und das ist BF3.
Also, ja.
Mischmasch.
Und es ist beschlossen, es mal im August zu veröffentlichen.
Und das ist nicht das erste Mal, dass er vom alten Battlefield Video holt.
Einige Wochen vor, hat er ein neues Melee-Waffen gefunden,
das an die Geschichte einer einzigartigen Kriegsfpuhr befasst ist.
Der Community-Manager hat uns auch Informationen gegeben,
über die kommenden Veränderungen...
Wisst ihr, was ich witzig finde?
Bei diesen ganzen Leaks, gerade was Battlefield und wie wir durchkämmen,
irgendwelche Gamefights...
Ich meine, vieles von dem, was geleakt wurde,
gibt es ja bis heute nicht.
es ja bis heute nicht. Umgedreht,
es wurden auch ein paar Sachen gefunden, gerade die
größeren, die gibt es jetzt. Ja, die neue Map
wurde ja schon vor einem halben Jahr vorher
geleakt. Aber
ist von den Leakern
noch nie einer davon ausgegangen, dass
die einfach lazy copy-pasted haben
aus alten Battlefield-Games
und dementsprechend dort Sachen drin
sind, die sie schlicht und ergreifend mit rein
copy-pasted haben, weil sie
faul waren? Ich meine, bei DICE
kann ich mir das alles vorstellen.
Die haben gesagt, ah, wir brauchen mal
ein paar Animationen zum Testen
für ein Assault-Rifle. Was nehmen wir denn?
Ach komm, lass uns mal kurz hier einfach
das Assault-Rifle-Pack aus Battlefield
4 reinziehen. Jetzt hast du halt die
Assault-Rifle aus Battlefield 4 da drinnen.
Und irgendjemand hat vergessen, dort irgendwie
das Fleck zu setzen, irgendwie copy-to-build
oder so. Der Kram ist halt
einfach da, aber der ist überhaupt nicht geplant
für das Game.
Unfortunately, back in the real world,
two out of three men experience
hair loss by the age of 35.
But there is hope if you want to maintain
your sexy gaming hair
indefinitely. Today's sponsor keeps
die
Wir machen jetzt schon Werbung für
anti-aging Haarzeug.
Jetzt, wenn es jetzt daran sieht,
man Gaming ist in der Mitte der Gesellschaft
angekommen.
...as you cover through
...so pervading keeps
...talk with their expert...
...and while it takes anywhere between 4...
und zwölf Monate, um die Fotos zu starten,
und das smooth gamer Haar zu behalten.
Slash Level 50%
Okay, von denen habe ich noch keine E-Mail bekommen.
Für die könnte ich aber tatsächlich Werbung machen.
Also mit meinem Real-Life-Haar könnte ich dafür Werbung machen,
wenn das wirklich funktioniert.
Das wird wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren.
Das ist aber seit Release schon bekannt gewesen
und die haben irgendwie jetzt wieder Monate gebraucht,
da was zu fixen.
Wir dürfen nicht vergessen, DICE sagt,
es arbeitet immer noch ein großes Team
und quasi fast komplett DICE an diesem Spiel.
Das ist halt einfach Bullshit, habe ich ja schon öfters gesagt,
weil, wie gesagt, es gibt die Auswahl,
sie sind einfach komplett unfähig oder EA lügt uns an
und ich tippe in dem Fall mal tatsächlich.
EA lügt uns an.
Was? Ja, Standard ist.
Ja, da bin ich gespannt.
Das ist, wie gesagt, heute Abend BF3 Reality Mod.
Heute Abend.
Heute Abend, 20 Uhr, glaube ich.
Ja, 20 Uhr.
Ich werde es mir mal angucken,
aber ich glaube nicht,
dass das für mich das Richtige ist,
weil, wie gesagt, ich mochte Battlefield 3,
weil es Battlefield 3 ist und nicht,
weil es Squad ist.
Aber gut.
Leute, lasst mal kurz überlegen.
Hatte Battlefield 3 eigentlich schon Voice-Over-IP
standardmäßig?
Oder musste man das über Portal irgendwie machen?
Nee, nee, das hatte kein Voice-Over-IP, oder?
Standardmäßig.
Du musstest das über Xbox Party oder Portal machen.
Hatte BF3 VoIP?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, hatte keins.
Aber die haben wahrscheinlich eins, gehe ich mal von aus.
Oder, oder, aber, oder du musst auf den Discord oder so.
Oder auf TS, auf TS, oder?
Mal gespannt.
Bin mal gespannt, ob die das reinpatchen können.
Ich meine, es ist ja,
also diese ganze Venice Unleashed-Geschichte
ist ja so ein Aufsatz auf Battlefield 3
mit irgendwelchen Lua-Skripts.
Keine Ahnung, ob man dort sowas wie VoIP nachpatchen kann.
Da bin ich, da bin ich tatsächlich mal gespannt.
Features und Roadmap.
Die haben tatsächlich Team-Chat eingebaut in Battlefield 3.
Nicht schlecht.
Du hast gestern schon gespielt, die haben Ingame-Voice.
Also das musst du erst mal auf die Reihe kriegen,
das da reinzuhackermänen.
Wobei die es wahrscheinlich nicht wirklich in Battlefield 3 eingebaut haben.
Das ist bestimmt irgendwie richtig heftiger Trick,
was die da gezogen haben.
So nach dem Motto, es ist eigentlich nur ein zweites Programm,
was ein Overlay über dem Game ist oder irgendwie sowas.
Ich gehe davon aus, das ist ein richtig krasser Trick.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die VoIP in Frostbite eingebaut bekommen haben.
Aber ich meine, letztendlich ist es wurscht, das funktioniert.
Freifeld.
Also ich werde es heute Abend auf jeden Fall ausprobieren,
aber nicht im Stream.
Ähm, mal gucken, wie gesagt, ich glaube nicht, dass es was für mich ist.
Aber ich bin gespannt.
The mod is very similar to the Hit Tactical Shooter Squad.
And this of course is no surprise,
as that game is actually based on an old Battlefield 2 mod called Project Reality.
Die übrigens nichts mit Battlefield 3 Reality Mod zu tun haben.
Ja, ich denke auch, dass es in HTML auf...
Also der Launcher ist ja irgendwie ein Browser oder so.
Und, ja, ich vermute auch, dass es in Overlay ist.
Ohne, dass ich es gesehen habe.
Ich gucke mir das nachher an.
Vielleicht gucken wir es uns auch im Stream an.
Aber ich kann halt im Stream nicht in Discord gescheit.
Ich weiß nicht, andere kriegen das gebacken.
Ich habe es auch schon ein paar Mal probiert,
aber ich kann nicht streamen, spielen und Discord reden dabei.
Das kriege ich mit meinem Hirn nicht mehr hin.
Ich kann spielen und streamen.
Ich kann Discord reden mit Leuten und spielen.
Aber ich kann nicht drei Sachen auf einmal.
Möb, danke schön für den Sub.
Also, das könnte ich dann höchstens ohne.
Ohne Discord oder ohne Ingame VoIP streamen.
Oder Ingame VoIP auf leise machen, dass ich halt wenigstens die Leute höre.
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ja.
Vielleicht gucken wir uns das heute Abend wirklich zusammen an.
... und Spawn-System.
Es bietet auch Wettbewerbe von über 100 Spielern mit Ingame VoIP.
Reality-Mod startet auf PC am 17. Juli.
Um zu spielen, musst du die Venice Unleashed Clients downloaden und...
Zack, Zack, Zack, Zack.
Venice.
Wie sehen da die offiziellen Server gerade aus?
Wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Oh ne, fuck.
Kein Schimmer, weißt du jetzt nicht mehr.
Muss ich nachher raussuchen, keine Ahnung.
Kackel.
... auch eine Kopie von Battlefield 3 brauchen.
Spieler können dedizierte Server kreieren...
... und die Anwendungen so gut sie wollen.
Ein Dataminer...
Doch, aber nicht hier.
... auf Twitter hat viele Informationen über Modern Warfare 2 verlinkt.
Aufgrund dessen...
Das ist gar keine, keine schlechte Idee.
Ich guck mal auf dem zweiten Rechner, ob ich Venice da eingetragen hab.
Ups.
Falscher Knopf.
Venice. Nein, hab ich nicht eingetragen.
Na geil.
Ich hoffe, die haben Passwort-Reset oder so.
Naja.
Schauen wir mal.
Ja, mach ich, mach ich.
Kannst du kurz erklären, wieso ich steige aktuell in das Thema der...
Ja, also...
Ja, kommt drauf an.
Was du, was du für Themen machst.
Ja.
Also wenn's um irgendwie Continuous Integration, Continuous Delivery geht, da kommt's halt ganz drauf an.
Was stellt ihr für Software her, für das du Tools bereitstellst?
Was baut ihr für Software?
Was setzt ihr ein?
Du kannst das zum größten Teil alles mit C-Sharp machen, wobei man halt sagen muss, auch Python ist in diesem Umfeld ziemlich beliebt.
Funktioniert beides, ja? Funktioniert beides.
Wenn ihr jetzt natürlich .NET-Software habt, die ihr bauen wollt oder deployen wollt oder testen wollt oder was auch immer.
Ich denke mal, dann würde sich's anbieten, das Ganze auf C-Sharp-Basis zu machen, weil die Tests sind dann in C-Sharp programmiert, die Software ist in C-Sharp programmiert, das Bild geht über .NET.
Das kommt ein bisschen drauf an, um was es geht, ja?
Also ich kann dir aber sagen, warum ich das bevorzuge, zumindest für so die normalen Sachen, die ich mache.
Das liegt genau greifend daran, weil ich mehr Ahnung von .NET habe, weil ich .NET schon länger und regelmäßiger verwende.
Und weil ich sagen muss, dass die Sachen, die ich bisher von Python gesehen hab, was wir uns hier auch zusammen im Stream angeguckt haben, so cool das ist für kleine Sachen.
Und so cool das wahrscheinlich auch ist für...
...größere Sachen, wo man dann in irgendeinem Container deployen kann oder so.
So problematisch stelle ich mir das vor, könnt ihr mich ja korrigieren, wenn ihr die krassen Python-Checker seid, für so mittlere Sachen.
Zum Beispiel, stellt euch mal vor, ihr wollt irgendein Kommandozeilen-Tool entwickeln, mit dem ihr...
Nehmen wir mal ein aktuelles Beispiel, ja?
Ich hab mir überlegt, ich bastel ein kleines Tool bei uns auf der Arbeit.
Das kommt auf jeden Server drauf, das kommt auf jede VM drauf, was Maintenance für diesen Server setzt.
Also mal angenommen, irgendjemand hat im Change-Management-Meeting beantragt, er möchte jetzt hier irgendwie Server XY irgendwas umstellen und muss den Server rebooten.
Keine Ahnung, will Kernel-Update machen auf dem Server, muss rebooten.
Was bei uns öfters mal vergessen wird, ist, dass die Leute das zwar angekündigt haben, dass sie jetzt Wartungsarbeiten auf dem System machen.
Aber sie vergessen, das Monitoring auszuschalten.
Das Monitoring auszuschalten für das System.
So, und da wollte ich ein kleines Tool basteln, wo du einfach vom System selber dieses System in Maintenance setzen kannst.
Was relativ easy ist.
Du brauchst im Prinzip ein Push-Request auf den Prometheus Alert Manager für den Host-Name.
Das ist relativ simpel.
Und das sind so kleinere Sachen.
Ich wollte da noch ein paar Optionen einfügen, so nach dem Motto, du kannst noch einen Kommentar hinzufügen und du kannst auch noch...
Die Duration setzen, wann du sowas willst.
Ja, das wäre dann so ein Skript, das heißt dann Maintenance Now.
Und da habe ich mir überlegt, ja gut, ich könnte ja mal eine Library für Python nehmen, mit der ich schöne Terminal, schönen Terminal-Output machen kann.
Ja, dass das schön farbig ist oder vielleicht auch Anzeigen in der Tabelle, dass die Maintenance ist.
Und dann gibt es ja zig Libraries für so etwas.
Jetzt ist bloß das Problem, wie bundle ich dieses Skript gescheit, dass ich das auf unsere Server schieben kann.
So, da gibt es ein paar...
Also, das ist das Problem.
Da gibt es ein paar...
Also, das Deployment finde ich bei Python irgendwie ein bisschen eklig.
Vielleicht habe ich auch noch nicht so den optimalen Weg gefunden.
Also, du kannst, wenn du ein einzelnes Skript-File hast, ist es easy.
Und wenn du nur die Standard-Library verwendest, ist es auch easy.
Dann baust du das, schiebst das auf das System drauf und hoffst, dass da halt eine...
Ja, nee, so einfach ist es nicht.
Und dann hoffst du halt, dass dort ein Python-Interpreter drauf ist, der neu genug ist, dass dein Skript läuft mit dem, was du verwendest.
Was wahrscheinlich so ist.
Wenn du die Standard-Library benutzt.
Das ist der einfache Fall.
Dann ist es gar kein Ding.
Aber ich meine, so ein paar Libraries verwenden ist ja schon ganz nice.
Gerade für Konsolenausgabe, für ein bisschen schöner formatieren und sonst was.
So, die nächste Variante ist, man macht sich so einen Bundle.
Das Bundle aus allen Dependencies, deinem Programm und einer Python-Runtime.
Dann läuft das...
Moin, schön, dass du deinen Weg hierher gefunden hast.
Ähm...
Oh, fuck.
Wo bin ich stehen geblieben?
Ähm...
Ja, genau.
Also du machst ein...
Wir gucken gleich weiter.
Aber das muss ich jetzt mal ein bisschen ausführlicher beantworten.
Und zwar, du kannst ein Bundle draus machen.
Das ist dann ein Binary-Bundle mit der passenden Python-Runtime, mit deinem Skript und allen Dependencies.
Das Problem bei PyInstaller ist...
Wenn du das auf deinem System laufen lässt...
Dann läuft das nicht zwangsläufig auf dem System, wo du das verwenden willst.
Und außerdem kommt ein relativ großes Binary raus, was du wahrscheinlich auch nicht in dein Git-Repo einchecken willst.
Um es dann auf alle Server zu verteilen.
Da ist so ein Plain-Text-Skript schon schöner.
So.
Und du musst, dass das funktioniert...
Müsstest du dir quasi einen lokalen Build-Container bauen, der alt genug ist, dass es alle deine Systeme unterscheidet.
Auf die du es am Ende deployen willst.
Das ist das Schöne von Go.
Ihr habt es gestern gesehen, ich bin weder der große Go-Checker noch der große Go-Fan.
Aber dieses Problem hat Go halt komplett gelöst.
Du kompilierst ein Go-Programm, schiebst das irgendwo drauf auf ein Linux-System der letzten 12 Jahre und es geht.
So.
Also PyInstaller ist dafür schon mal für so kleine Hilfertools schon mal...
Hilfertools gar nicht mal so gut.
Weil es höchstwahrscheinlich auf deinem Server nicht richtig läuft.
Wenn du es auf deinem Desktop mit PyInstaller bauen kannst.
Du müsstest dir höchstens auf deinem Desktop irgendeinen Uralt-Docker-Container nehmen.
Und das da bilden und dann funktioniert das.
Die ganze Setup-Tools-Geschichte ist auch nicht schön.
Oder auch das als Wheel bauen ist auch ein bisschen problematisch.
Weil dann müsste ich quasi wieder...
Weil Wheels sind ja im Prinzip gezippte Zip-Files mit allem möglichen drin.
Die kannst du dann auf den Server kopieren und dort musst du dann pip install machen.
Ja, das wird funktionieren.
Dann bräuchte ich aber irgendwie...
Das könnt ihr auch nicht in meinem Git-Repo gescheit einchecken.
Es sei denn, man ist okay, dass man halt irgendwie mal ab und zu mal Binarys eincheckt.
Ja, okay.
Könnte ich einchecken und dann müsste ich irgendwie...
Config-Management schreiben, copy rüber auf den Server und dann mach pip install local-wheel so.
Ist auch irgendwie doof.
Warum gibt es nicht die Möglichkeit, das zu bundlen?
Als Plaintext.
Vielleicht gibt es das ja, vielleicht weiß ich nicht.
Ja.
Also warum gibt es nicht die Möglichkeit, dass man sich einen Ordner generieren lässt,
den ich dann einfach auf den...
Einen Ordner mit einem Einstiegsscript, den ich dann einfach aufs Zielsystem kopiere.
Also in dem Ordner sind alle Abhängigkeiten außer der Interpreter, der kann vom System kommen, drinnen.
Und dann ist gut.
Weiß nicht, das wäre tatsächlich ganz praktisch.
Ach ja, die andere Möglichkeit ist natürlich auch, dass man einen dieser ganzen...
Python-Compiler nimmt, die es gibt.
Wie heißt das?
Äh...
Gibt es auch, so zwei, drei.
Da kommen dann auch Binarys raus, ist auch nicht so schön.
Also gerade für das, wo ich es gut gebrauchen könnte, irgendwelche semi-komplexen Hilfstools für unsere Systeme,
dafür eignet es sich irgendwie nicht so gut.
Wobei sich da von der Sprache her gut eignen würde.
Oder ich habe noch nicht the way gefunden, wie man das gescheit benutzt in der Richtung.
Das habe ich auch gesehen.
Das habe ich auch schon gesehen.
Da gibt es PyOxidizer oder wie das heißt.
In Rust-Binary verpacken.
Das habe ich auch schon gesehen, dass das geht.
Wenn du ein Standalone-Skript machst, dann hast du ja nicht alle Abhängigkeiten dabei, die du brauchst.
Stell dir mal vor, du machst ein Skript mit Kommandozeilen-Ausgaben und sonst was und willst es ein bisschen schöner formatieren.
Und du hast keinen Bock drauf, Tabellen selbst auszurechnen, wie du Tabellen schön formatierst im Terminal.
Du verwendest irgendeine Library für.
Du machst in deinem lokalen Projekt PIP-Install.
Ich habe vergessen, wie es heißt.
Das Python-Gegenstück zu Spectre-Console.
Das, wovon Spectre-Console inspiriert ist.
Machst du drauf und gut ist.
Ja, ich weiß, das ist ja gerade das Dumme.
Das ist ja gerade das Blöd.
Rich, Rich meine ich.
Richtig.
So.
Und.
Dann hast du halt kein Standalone-Skript.
Dann hast du dann quasi dein Skript plus halt die Imports und in einem anderen Ordner die Abhängigkeiten.
Irgendwo.
Weiß nicht, ob ich den Ordner einfach rüber kopieren.
Geht ja wahrscheinlich nicht, weil die Version so neu ist und die Python-Runtime auf dem Server nicht unterstützt.
Also das ist irgendwie.
Weiß ich nicht.
Das ist so ein bisschen.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Ich habe da noch nicht so die optimale Sache gefunden.
Chronix, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Nee, ganz bestimmt nicht.
Ich push bestimmt keine Inputs.
Ich push bestimmt keine internen Tools irgendwie auf ein öffentliches Repo.
Nee, Packs brauche ich auch nicht.
Packs sind.
Zipfalls.
Vielleicht gibt es da auch keine sinnvolle Lösung für.
Ach so.
Ja.
Ja, aber da müsste ich das Skript rüber kopieren.
Da müsste ich ein pip install darauf machen.
Ist alles.
Ist alles irgendwie ein bisschen.
Ich will was, was ich einfach auf die Systeme drauf kriege.
Und ich glaube nicht, dass ich für ein simples Kommandozeilen-Tool zu Maintenance setzen,
noch Firewall-Freischaltung und Proxy-Freischaltung beantragen will.
Geschweige denn, dass ich dort irgendwelche pip installs machen will mit Paketen von der externen Registry,
wo dann wahrscheinlich der Windows Defender noch rummeckert.
Wir sind im Business Enterprise Umfeld.
Da ist das leider so kacke gemacht.
Du kannst da nicht einfach irgendwas drauf kopieren und ausführen.
Ich finde das auch kacke, aber das geht nicht so einfach.
Da hängt saumäßig viel dran.
Also wenn ich jetzt einfach sage, ich will pip install machen auf dem Server.
Das geht nicht so einfach.
Das geht auf meinen Kisten einfach.
Und das geht wahrscheinlich auf den meisten Kisten einfach.
Aber nicht im Business Bank Enterprise Strongs Umfeld.
Da ist mit pip install auf irgendwelchen Server nichts.
Ich komme wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal zum Repo raus.
Zur Registry raus.
Es wäre wahrscheinlich einfacher für mich, ein Docker-Container zu bauen und den irgendwie als tar-File darüber zu schieben und dort auszuführen.
Anstatt pip install zu machen.
Oder aber, ich mache es in Go.
Da ist das Binary zwar auch ein Binary, aber kleiner.
Oder in Rust.
Oder in .NET.
Mit einem Ahead-of-Time-Compile in Binary.
Gestripte Debug-Symbols.
Ist das auch nur irgendwie 10 MB oder so groß?
Ne, in C++ mache ich das bestimmt nicht.
Ich will ja immerhin, ich will ja zumindest noch ein bisschen Entwicklungskomfort haben.
Dann...
Ich weiß nicht, ich könnte ja wahrscheinlich den Wield rausbauen, auf den Server kopieren und dann pip install local package oder so machen.
Ich könnte auch JavaScript machen, ja.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Mal überlegen.
Die einfachste Variante.
Wisst ihr, was für mich wirklich die allereinfachste Variante wäre?
Wenn es die Möglichkeit gäbe...
Single-File-Deployment.
Was kein...
Binary ist.
Also, was kein kompiliertes Zeug ist, wie PyInstaller.
Dass der quasi deine ganzen Abhängigkeiten irgendwie inline anhängt unter deinem Code oder so.
Was natürlich abartig ist, aber es würde besser funktionieren, es wäre ein File, es wäre Klartext und ich müsste es einfach nur rüberkopieren und es wäre da.
Aber ich glaube, sowas gibt es wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ja, das ist das einzige, was ich machen kann.
Ich kann beispielsweise...
Das werde ich wahrscheinlich auch so machen.
Ich mache ein Python-Skript ohne.
Ich benutze halt einfach nur Standard-Library.
Ich meine, damit kannst du auch grafische Konsolenausgabe machen oder so.
Weil ich habe mir überlegt, ich kopiere einfach auf alle unsere Server, auf alle unsere VMs ein Skript drauf.
Ja, C++, Alter, MonkaS.
Ich kopiere auf alle unsere Systeme ein Skript drauf, wo du direkt Maintenance setzen kannst.
Ähm...
Theoretisch würde das wahrscheinlich mit Ansible auch funktionieren.
Es...
Ja, aber nicht vom System aus selbst.
Aber nicht vom System aus selbst.
Das müsstest du dann wahrscheinlich von deinem Host machen.
Von deinem Host kannst du einfach im Browser in Alert Manager gehen.
Ne, also das Einfachste ist wirklich...
Du könntest das mit Ansible machen, aber es ist einfach...
Ich will, dass du auf die Kommandozeile gehen kannst und sagst dann sowas hier.
Ne, wobei nicht .slash.
Du sagst dann irgendwie, ähm...
Okay, ich darf es nicht Maintenance nennen, weil niemand kann Maintenance schreiben.
Kennt jemand...
Kennt jemand gute Synonyme für Maintenance?
Oder auf Deutsch?
Leute!
Ich bin bei ner...
Ich bin bei ner deutschen Bank.
Die stehen auf deutsche Wörter.
Sag...
Sag mal irgendwas...
Wartung.
Wartung...
Jetzt Wartung.
Instandhaltung.
Set Downtime.
Das finde ich gut.
Das finde ich schön.
Ja.
Ne, wir machen das noch anders.
Wir nennen es Downtime Now.
So.
So nenne ich das.
Das würdest du dann so ausführen.
Oder einfach so.
Brauchst ja gar eine Endung.
Einfach Downtime Now.
So.
So nenne ich das.
Das würdest du dann so ausführen.
Oder einfach so.
Brauchst ja gar eine Endung.
Ein Downtime Now.
So.
Und das gibts dann...
Und da gibt es dann als einzige Option noch...
Genau.
Als einzige Option.
Duration.
Sowas in der Richtung.
Könntest du noch machen.
Ansonsten.
Default sind 15 Minuten.
Und äh...
Ja so Comment.
Comment.
Würd ich noch machen.
Ähm...
Könnt ihr es auch...
Man könnte es auch Wartung nennen oder so.
Aber ich glaube Downtime Now ist...
Ist fast besser.
So und dann könnte man auch vielleicht noch minus C machen für nen Comment.
Dass man dann sagt hier irgendwie...
Kämpft.
Kekkel Reboot oder so.
Okay, was findet ihr schöner,
Chat? Wir gucken gleich
weiter. Ich weiß, wir
schweifen etwas ab. Was
findet ihr schöner? Downtime
now, minus D, zwei Stunden
oder
Wartung
jetzt. Wartung
jetzt, Duration zwei
Wartung, es
müsste minus minus jetzt sein.
Komm, wir machen now.
Wir machen now, ja?
Oder, Wartung
minus minus now.
Man könnte es auch postchamp, das fände
ich geil. Stellt euch mal vor, Leute,
das ist die, das ist die
Gelegenheit, Twitch-Emotes auf alle unsere
Systeme zu bringen. Postchamp
heißt das Ding. Postchamp
now.
Das kann sich dann aber dort wieder keiner merken.
Das ist aber nur, das behalte ich im
Hinterkopf, Leute. Ich bringe Twitch-Emotes auf
alle unsere Server und VMs und Azure-Kisten
und sonst was. Twitch-Emotes.
So muss das sein. Bad game, bad game.
Pause, verstehen die Leute aber
noch. Postchamp checken die Leute.
Bad game checkt keiner.
Postchamp
auch irgendjemand, der
Wartungsmeister.
Wartemeister.
Ich mein, ich mein,
für mich wäre Bad game now sehr cool
als Kommandozeile, ja?
Aber das versteht, das versteht wieder keiner.
Aber Postchamp verstehen die
Leute, weil es ist halt Pause.
Und Champ haben sich die Leute schon dran
gewöhnt, dass ich an meine Tools gerne Champ
hinten dran hänge.
Aber ich persönlich würde wahrscheinlich diese Variante
immer noch bevorzugen.
Weil Downtime now
können sich die Leute
halt einfach merken.
Ich mein, man könnte ja now auch noch
überschreiben, ja? Man könnte dann irgendwie
sagen, minus S
20 Uhr oder so.
Irgendwie so. Das ist halt nicht
now, sondern 20 Uhr.
Man könnte es auch nennen
Wartungsarbeiten
aktivieren.
Minus, minus, minus,
minus jetzt.
Nee, gar nix. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie wir
drauf gekommen sind. Eigentlich waren wir
gerade bei Levelcamp Video gucken.
Und die ursprüngliche Frage war, warum ich
.NET lieber verwende.
Äh.
Ach hier, okay, da hat einer noch was geschrieben.
Die Firma hat hauptsächlich ASP,
ich hoffe, es ist ASP.NET Core und nicht
wirklich noch .NET Framework ASP.NET.
Ja, also,
wenn deine Firma hauptsächlich
.NET macht, dann würde ich sagen,
bietet sich das auch an,
das in .NET zu machen.
Weil, ich gehe mal davon aus, also ich weiß
ja nicht genau, was du machen sollst. Also ich gehe mal davon
aus, wenn du, wenn du irgendwas
mit Continuous Integration, Continuous Delivery
machen sollst, einer der ersten Schritte ist ja,
es gibt ein Merge Request, du checkst
erstmal prinzipiell, hat der Typ richtig
Rebased, lässt sich das mergen und als nächstes
lässt du ein Test Environment
laufen oder ein Container laufen und machst mal
die Tests, die in dem Projekt drin sind.
So, die Tests sind in .NET,
du musst nicht zwangsläufig,
deine, ja, Sachen drumherum
auch in .NET machen,
aber, ich weiß nicht, irgendwie würde
sich das anbieten, wenn das, wenn das
.NET Microservices sind.
Ein ASCII Pause Champ.
Das ist gut. Wir machen dann
Ausgabe, die erste, die erste Ausgabe
ist dann Echo
Pause Champing.
Also,
ich würde mir auf jeden Fall C-Sharp
angucken, allein schon, selbst wenn du das nicht
für deine Pipelines oder für deine
Tests oder für was auch immer, was du da machst,
brauchst. Zumindest verstehst du dann ein
bisschen besser, was die da eigentlich
programmiert haben. Und das ist ja auch
nicht verkehrt, wenn du ein bisschen auch
noch für die Infrastruktur und Server
und sonst was zuständig bist.
Darf ich nicht vergessen, viele Leute, die
jetzt in diesem Bereich sind, waren früher
mal Linux Admins. Es ist nicht verkehrt zu
verstehen, was da eigentlich drauf läuft.
Ja, also das, das schadet auf jeden Fall
nicht. Was ich, was ich persönlich an
C-Sharp und .NET wirklich sehr mag, auch,
was ich nicht mag, ist, dass es von
Microsoft ist. Aber gut, man ist halt so.
Was mir an der, was mir an der, also im
ganzen .NET Ökosystem wirklich gut
gefällt, ist, dass Microsoft wirklich ein
richtig angenehmes Tempo vorlegt für
Fixes und vor allem für neue Sachen, ja.
Die updaten das öfters mal, wenn was
komplett im Arsch ist, aber sie bringen
einmal im Jahr eine neue Major-Version
raus oder neue Versionen raus.
Sie hatten auch mal sowas wie .NET 3.1, aber ich glaube,
aktuell zählen sie einfach durch. Sie bringen
jedes Jahr eine neue Major-Version raus,
sowohl von .NET als auch einen neuen
C-Sharp-Standard. Als nächstes sind wir, glaube ich,
bei C-Sharp 11 und bei .NET 7. Das heißt,
nächstes Jahr sind wir dann, nächstes Jahr
November sind wir dann bei .NET 8. Ich
finde, ein Jahr ist genau der richtige
Zeitpunkt dafür, zumal es laufend Preview-Versionen
gibt und du kannst dir den ganzen Kram
immer permanent angucken, was es Neues
gibt. Und die Features, die sie einbauen,
sind jetzt zum größten Teil auch immer
noch sinnvoll und praktisch.
Als ich gestern gesehen habe, wie man in
Go beispielsweise Jason deserialisieren
kann und dort verschiedene Felder
exkluden kann, da musste ich schon ein
bisschen cringen. Bei in .NET würde ich
einfach ein Attribut drüber machen mit
Jason Ignore. Ich könnte
den Pause-Champ to ASCII, Moment,
Image to ASCII. Da gab es doch
für Linux ein schönes Tool, was das
macht.
JPA? Moment, Moment, das muss ich kurz, das
muss kurz ausprobiert werden, Leute. Ich
brauche ein Pause-Champ. Ich brauche ein
Pause-Champ in ASCII-Art. Ich gebe zu, es hat
nichts mit dem Stream jetzt zu tun, aber
das muss ich jetzt schnell ausprobieren.
Pause-Champ in ASCII-Art. GitHub. Was gab's
denn da schönes? Image to ASCII.
Sowas, sowas, sowas will ich machen, genau.
Image, Image to ASCII, genau. Ah, ah, ja, ja, Fan.
Sowas, genau. Das muss ich jetzt ausprobieren, ob das mit dem,
ich brauche ein ASCII, ASCII-Pause-Champ.
Zack. Das müssen wir jetzt ausprobieren.
Was, Bing Image of the Day? Irgendwas in
Australien wahrscheinlich. Wählt man in der
Physieausbildung viel programmieren? Ne, das
Ganze, was du da in der Berufsschule lernst,
ist komplett useless eigentlich. Ah, bisschen
was wenigstens. Äh, Pause-Champ. Braucht man das
Bild? Ja, Pause-Champ. Was? Ja, meinetwegen auch
bei Pauli Lull. Save Image. Downloads, Pause-Champ.
CD, Downloads, Image to ASCII. Jetzt, Image to ASCII.
Aus dem Auer. Image. Hm. ASCII-Image. Gibt's da
irgendwas Fertiges, was, mit dem, mit dem man das
machen kann? Image. Hier. JP2A. Pause-Champ. Leute, da ist er.
Hi-Res Pause-Champ. Hi-Res ASCII Pause-Champ. So
muss das sein. Muss aber gucken, ob man da
irgendwelche Auflösungen setzen kann. Hier,
Width, Height, ja. Minus, minus Colors kann das auch.
Oh, guckt mal hier. Guckt mal hier. Das ist ja wie
original, Alter. So, jetzt wollen wir hier, Breite, 80.
Ne, gleich, gleich 80. Irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 20.
Ja, gut. Müsst, müsst man sich irgendwas überlegen.
Okay. Ey, guck mal. Guck mal, Leute, man erkennt das sogar.
Man muss halt die Pixel, man muss halt die Pixel kleiner
machen. Und man kann das bestimmt noch, man kann das
bestimmt noch irgendwie tunen, dass es besser aussieht als
so. Beziehungsweise besser, besser aussieht als so. Und
das dann, der muss kleinere Buchstaben verwenden. Die sind
zu groß, die Buchstaben. Ne, gut. Zumindest, wir haben
Pause, Pause-Champ generated als ASCII. Perfekt. Weiter. So.
Und jetzt, und jetzt gucken wir aber mal Videos weiter. Kann man
sich nach der Physi aus, du hast recht, das müssen wir noch
machen. Ja, das, das müssen wir hallo? Meine VM hängt. Das,
das müssen wir noch schnell, das müssen wir noch schnell machen.
Ganz, ganz wichtig. Du musst dich nicht nach der Physi
Ausbildung ausprogrammieren, spezialisieren. Du kannst auch
was programmieren. Während der Physi-Ausbildung, es kommt auf
den Betrieb an, wo du bist. Ja, nur dass man das in der
Berufsschule lernt, automatisch ist halt nicht so. Wenn du in
nem Laden bist, gerade wenn das äh vielleicht ne äh
ähm der in Betrieb ist, der auch äh schon viele Sachen in
der Cloud laufen hat und vielleicht dort irgendwelche
Functions oder du irgendwelche Infrastruktur automatisieren
kannst oder so, dann kannst du auch viel programmieren als
Physi. Aber halt standardmäßig, was du in der Berufsschule
lernst, ist für'n Arsch. So, Leute. Bester Pause-Champ, hier.
Kappa Pride Pause-Champ. Ich bin überrascht, wie gut das
aussieht.
Minus-Minus-Phil. Oh, ist ein bisschen klein. Äh. Alter. High
Res. Massive. RTX on. Alter, das sieht ja richtig gut aus.
HD. Das sieht ja richtig gut aus. Guck mal hier für das,
das ist, ich mein, das ist, das ist einfach nur Terminal. Okay,
es geht nur mit nem, mit nem äh True Color Terminal, aber
trotzdem, das ist nice. Okay, ich weiß, was bei uns als
neues, als, als neues Login Prompt kommt. Nee, als Login
Prompt kann ich das nicht machen. Als, als Wartungs, als,
als Wartungsding. Und kann ich jetzt noch? Das ist echt nicht
schlecht. Das gefällt mir. So, okay. Jetzt aber. Schluss ist.
So, weiter im Text. Nee, wahrscheinlich, weil er ne
Physi-Stelle hat. Und wahrscheinlich, weil er's auch
nicht schlecht findet, aber er würde gerne ein bisschen
mehr programmieren. Also, wie gesagt, kommt vom, hängt vom
da ab wie? Warum fragst du? Also, was ist der? Was ist der
genaue Hintergrund? So, aber jetzt gucken wir erst mal
Level Cap weiter.
Game Modes. These include popular modes like Gunfight and
Hardpoint with new ones like. Also, ich bin so absolut null
gehyped auf Modern Warfare zwei. Ich werd's wahrscheinlich
spielen. Das ist halt das Schlimme bei mir. Ähm okay, das
letzte, die letzten Call of Vanguard hab ich mir nicht
gekauft und Cold War hab ich mir an... Doch!
Ne, warte mal. Doch!
Cold War hatte ich mir
gekauft. Vanguard hab ich mir nicht gekauft.
...all or nothing and ground war
bomb. Killstreak rewards include
a UAV, fuel bomb, smoke
airdrop, thermobaric strike and
a cluster spike. Most of this
information was data mined from the...
Was ist eigentlich mit
dieser Modern Warfare...
Was ist los mit den Modern Warfare Leuten?
Warum haben die alle so Pausbäckchen?
Guckt euch die Charaktere
an. Guckt euch Captain Bryce an.
Guckt euch Soap an.
Die haben alle so Pausbäckchen.
Was ist mit ihren
Model-Erstellern los?
Mögen die das, wenn die alle so aussehen wie nach
Weisheitszahn-OP?
Der Typ
sieht aus... Guckt euch das mal an.
Der Typ sieht aus, als hätten
sie ihm gerade die Weisheitszähne rausgenommen.
Oder? Guckt mal!
Das ist... Okay, manche Leute
haben noch fettere Backen,
wenn sie Weisheitszähne
gezogen bekommen haben, aber
es sieht halt schon danach aus.
Ja, du kannst prinzipiell
alles machen, was du willst, denn du musst dich halt
dafür interessieren. Die
Unterschiede, gerade nach der Ausbildung
zwischen Physi und Fachinformatik
Anwendungsentwicklung, es ist eh nicht
vorhanden, je nachdem in welchem Bereich
du bist. Also
das ist rein...
Ja, was du
gerne machen willst und was du kannst.
Und natürlich, gerade in der Ausbildung
hängt es halt enorm stark vom Betrieb ab, wo du
bist.
Ja, wenn du jetzt beispielsweise bei einem
Rechenzentrumsbetreiber
arbeitest, der
wo du den ganzen Tag im Rechenzentrum
irgendwie Kabel ziehst, ja gut.
Oder ab und zu Switche konfigurierst und sowas.
Da ist wahrscheinlich mit
irgendwelchen tollen CI-Tools
und solch Programmieren nicht so viel.
Aber selbst da. Ich sag mal ganz im Ernst.
Also, mittlerweile
ist es gut,
wenn du in jedem Bereich
mein Druckerpatronen-Wechsler mal außen vor
ein bisschen programmierst.
Weil, auch wenn du rein im
klassischen Systemadministrationsbereich
bist. Heutzutage hast du viele
Server in der Cloud, du hast viele
virtualisierte Server und du hast viel
Potenzial, Abläufe zu automatisieren.
Und Abläufe zu automatisieren
schreit ja gerade nach
Automatisierung. Also sprich, irgendwas
was du programmierst. Man kann sich
jetzt drüber streiten, ja, ob
Ansible oder Puppet oder
Chef oder was es nicht alles da gibt.
Solstack, falls das irgendjemand verwendet.
Ähm, ob das
wirklich Programmieren ist. Aber nach meinem Geschmack
schon. Ich mein, was ist Programmieren?
Du hast irgendwie Syntax
und Schlüsselwörter, die dann
ausgeführt werden und am Ende das machen, was du
willst. Ja, du hast Kontrollstrukturen wie
Schleifen und Ifs und sonst was.
Also, ja, ist es
im Endeffekt. Ja,
googeln musst du eh können, überall.
Google musst du überall können.
Das ist eh der wichtigste Skill eines
Fachinformatikers. Du musst suchen können.
Oder generell eines der
wichtigsten Skills überhaupt in solchen
Jobs. Ja. Das ist tatsächlich
so. Also, Programmieren beibringen tut dir keiner.
Es gibt, bei den Amis ist das relativ
beliebt, dass es da irgendwelche Bootcamps gibt.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie das hier in Deutschland ist.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob sich das,
keine Ahnung, kann ich nix zu sagen.
Letztendlich muss man's eh für sich selbst
lernen. Du kannst, wenn du
denn schon ordentlich programmieren kannst, klar.
Was man sicherlich lernen muss,
ist, zusammenarbeiten im Team,
zusammenarbeiten mit anderen Leuten.
Ähm, vielleicht auch mal
das lesen, was andere programmiert haben,
selbst so programmieren, dass es andere lesen können.
Und solche Geschichten, ja.
Oder, dass man vielleicht jetzt sich nicht
um Feature A kümmern kann, weil Feature
B oder Fix B wichtiger ist.
Ja, solche Sachen lernt man dann mit der Zeit schon.
Aber so, an sich
logisch denken und programmieren
lernen, das ist eigentlich zu 90%
ja, wirklich Eigeninitiative.
Das ist ja gut, aber das muss
ja auch durch Eigeninitiative kommen. Ich meine,
wenn einer gar keinen Bock hat,
wenn einer gar keinen Bock hat, ähm,
warte mal,
hier, wenn einer gar keinen Bock hat,
das zu lernen, da kannst du ihm auch so einen Udemy-Kurs
vorsetzen, damit er nicht allzu viel
haben. Und dank GitHub
ist das ja glücklicherweise einfacher denn je.
Also, wenn du irgendein Problem hast, was
du lösen musst, gibt's zwei Sachen.
Stack Overflow
und GitHub gucken.
Und ich find das auch überhaupt nicht
verwerflich, sich da aus GitHub inspirieren
zu lassen.
Je nachdem, welche Lizenz der Code hat,
kannst du das theoretisch sogar copy-pasten.
Oder du lässt von GitHub CodePile
copy-pasten.
Was dann offiziell nicht copy-paste ist.
Aber sowas in der Richtung, ja.
Das ist so. Deswegen, ja, du brauchst wirklich
Eigeninitiative, sonst klappt das nicht.
Naja, also,
also, ich, ich,
das kann ich jetzt schwer einschätzen. Ich sag so,
wenn man auf was wirklich
Bock hat, oder sich
wirklich dafür interessiert, also ich kann
das, ich kann das zum Beispiel schlecht
trennen. Also, wenn mich jetzt
Technik XY interessiert,
dann beschäftige
ich mich da meistens privat damit,
schon lange bevor man sich damit irgendwann
mal vielleicht in der Firma beschäftigt, wenn
überhaupt. Einfach, weil es
mich interessiert, ja.
Äh, ja, den Eingebauten,
den Eingebauten,
niemand verwendet was an, doch, doch, es gibt
manche Hardcore-Leute, die verwenden Depper.
Aber, äh, den Eingebauten,
also,
also, Entity Framework Core,
das ist eigentlich das, was so gut wie jeder
verwendet. Also, wirst du,
ich, ich glaube, du wirst feststellen, dass die
.NET Standard Library ziemlich gut ist, mit der
Zeit. Äh, moin, MissApple80.
Und, dass
relativ
viele offizielle Microsoft Packages
gibt, die auch ziemlich gut sind.
Ja, also vieles, was nicht direkt
Standard Library ist, sind aber offizielle
Microsoft Packages. Ja, zum Beispiel
Entity Framework, also der offizielle
OM-Mapper, äh,
DB-Access-Dings von .NET
ist,
glaube ich, ja,
es ist keine, wobei, doch,
Moment, Leute, ist Entity Framework
Standard Library oder nicht? Ist Entity Framework
dabei, wenn ich den
Projekttyp auf Web,
Web-Anwendungen stelle oder nicht? Ich glaube
nicht. Ich glaube, man muss es, nee, doch,
Entity Framework ist dabei, was
du, was du als offizielles Package
nachinstallieren musst, sind, glaube ich, die ganzen
DB-Treiber, also zum Beispiel
SQLite oder Postgres oder sowas.
Ich glaube, die muss, aber das sind auch offizielle
Microsoft Packages. Ich glaube, die muss,
die musst du dir über, über Nougat nach, nach
installieren oder, ja,
runterladen fürs Projekt.
Aber das ist kein Ding. Wie gesagt, sind alles offizielle
Microsoft Packages und die tun, also,
es verwendet so gut wie,
wie jeder, äh, den offiziellen
OM-Mapper in .NET.
Nennt sich
das da,
haben wir sogar ein eigenes GitHub,
das da ist der offizielle
Datenbank-Access und
Mapper und es ist
ein Modern Object Database Mapper,
für .NET. Genau.
So sieht das dann aus. Ich vermute mal,
ich kenne Django selbst nicht, ich meine, ich weiß,
was es ist, ich habe auch schon mal Django-Code gesehen, aber noch nie was
in Django gemacht. Ich vermute mal,
dass DB-Access in Django
gar nicht so viel unterschiedlich aussehen
wird zu dem hier.
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
Ich weiß es nicht, aber ich, ich denke
mal nicht. Ne, ist echt so, also,
an, also, ich finde,
gute, gutes, ähm,
gute IT-Fachleute,
Experten, die können
alle bis zu einem gewissen Grad
programmieren. Ich meine, ich erwarte jetzt nicht,
dass irgendjemand, der sich hauptsächlich
um Windows Active Directory kümmert,
dass der Arduino C++
Microcontroller programmieren kann, richtig
gut. Das hat ja damit nichts zu tun. Aber
was ich von irgendeinem Windows Active Directory
Administrator erwarten würde, ist, dass er
PowerShell kann, zum Beispiel, was ja auch
eine Programmiersprache ist.
Hast du dir das meiste selbst beigebracht? Ja.
Und ich glaube,
das geht den meisten so.
Die Sachen, für die
man sich interessiert, die bringt man sich mehr oder
weniger selbst bei.
Das meiste habe ich mir selbst beigebracht.
Es gibt natürlich ein paar Sachen, die lernt man im Enterprise
Umfeld, ja. Zum Beispiel habe ich daheim
noch nie ein Storage-System angeschlossen.
Das habe ich damals bei meiner Ausbildung im Provider
gemacht, beim Provider gemacht, weil, naja,
äh, du hast daheim in der Regel kein
Fiber-Channel-Storage-System,
was mehrere Tonnen wiegt, bei dir,
ja, an der Abstellkammer stehen.
Ja, auch keine,
du hast auch keine
Kleinwagen-teuren Load-Balancer
im wackeligen Wagen
über die Straße gekarrt,
zum Selbstbeibringen.
Also, so ein paar Sachen lernt
man natürlich schon auf der Arbeit, aber so die ganzen
Technik-Skills, muss ich ehrlich
sagen, zum größten Teil
habe ich die privat gelernt
und konnte sie dann bei der Arbeit verwenden
und dort verbessern. Ja, also ich habe mir
irgendwas angeguckt,
ähm, wie Technologie
XY funktioniert und
ja, vielleicht haben wir das Ganze dann auch mal
verwendet später auf der Arbeit und dort
kannte ich es dann schon und habe das dann mal
praxistechnisch ausprobiert und
dementsprechend noch
noch besser gelernt, ja.
Ja, das ist nicht schlimm. Gerade wenn du, das ist nicht
schlimm, ich glaube, das ist fast normal für Leute, die
in der Ausbildung sind und sich für die Themengebiete
interessieren. Das ist normal.
Du musst jetzt auch mal ein paar Sachen durchprobieren, weil
ich glaube, es gibt kein
Berufsfeld oder kein
Einsatzfeld, was so
vielfältig ist, als das, was du am Ende machen
kannst, wenn du irgendwie in die IT gehst.
Ja, musst ja nicht als Fachinformatiker sein, aber
wenn du, das kann alles sein. Das kann von
Druckerpatronen tauschen sein, bis
Cloud-Architektur, bis
äh, Mainframe-Kobol,
bis, ähm,
Cloud-Entwicklung
mit irgendwelchen, auf Kubernetes
kann alles sein. Also,
es gibt
nix, was es nix gibt. Es gibt nix,
was es nicht gibt dort.
Es kann im Zweifelsfall auch
SAP oder sowas sein.
Also, du musst dir schon angucken,
deswegen ist es gar nicht so schlimm, dass du dort,
äh,
alles die mögliche anguckst, was denn
ja so dein, dein Gebiet ist, was dir gefällt.
Dir wird nicht alles gefallen, das kann ich dir
jetzt schon sagen. Also, bei mir ist es zum Beispiel so,
ich hab eine riesen Abneigung gegen Windows,
Windows-Desktop, Windows-Server, Active
Directory und sonstige Geschichten.
Das würde ich für kein Geld der Welt,
okay, vielleicht übertrieben, doch, würde ich,
würde ich, ich würde, also, das wäre
aber sehr teuer, wenn mich einer als
Windows-Admin einkaufen möchte.
Also, ich glaube, das wäre
eher so teuer, dass er das nicht machen würde.
Aber davon abgesehen, dass ich keine
Ahnung davon habe, also, warum sollte er das machen?
Also, es gibt so ein paar Dinge, auf die habe ich keinen
Bock. Und eins davon ist halt auf jeden Fall
Windows-Administration.
Also, das ist so, das ist so Zeug,
also, generell
Microsoft-Tools, ich kann's nicht ab.
Wir haben,
ich weiß nicht, ob ich euch die, ob ich euch die Geschichte
schon mal erzählt hab, der Felix
und ich, mit dem haben wir ja schon mal, mit dem hab ich
auch schon mal ein paar Videos gemacht,
der war bei mir mit, mit Azubi,
ähm,
der Felix und ich, wir sollten mal,
zwei
Plate-Center-Plates
in ein anderes Rechenzentrum bringen,
quer durch Frankfurt.
Und,
ja, es, HS22
oder HS21-Plates
waren, glaube ich, damals noch.
Sind solche Dinger gewesen.
So sehen die aus.
Die kamen dann in so ein Gehäuse rein,
da konntest du zwölf, ich glaube, zwölf waren's,
zwölf solcher Rechner hochkant stecken.
Und, ähm,
ich weiß nicht, was es gekostet hat,
ich glaub, irgendwie, 20 oder 30.000 Euro
in, in, in, in Vollausbau,
ähm, irgendwie mit
6, 90 Gigabyte RAM
damals und so, das ist schon ein bisschen her,
also, 6, 90 Gigabyte RAM war damals
mega viel, ich mein, ehrlich gesagt,
6, 90 Gigabyte RAM ist heute noch viel.
Überlegt euch mal, 2010
oder, oder,
nee, noch, das muss noch früher gewesen sein,
2009 oder so, überlegt euch mal,
ihr habt 2009,
äh, Plates, Plates gab mit
96, 2009,
96 Gigabyte RAM.
Das war wirklich richtig
teuer, der Kram.
Und wir sollten mal zwei solcher Dinger
quer durch Frankfurt in ein anderes Rechenzentrum tragen.
Warum hat man uns das machen lassen?
Ganz einfach, weil Azubis
in die U-Bahn und in die S-Bahn stellen
mit, äh, Plates unterm Arm
war halt,
äh, billig.
Ich glaub, das war,
ich glaub, das war der einzige Grund,
warum er das gemacht hat, ja.
Das war halt,
billig.
Und, da haben wir, da haben wir,
sind wir mit den Dingern unterm Arm,
ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob jeder nur eins hatte
oder jeder zwei, ich glaube, jeder hatte nur eins.
Und,
da haben wir dann, sind wir in die S-Bahn
und standen damit halt rum, die Leute
haben uns schon die ganze Zeit blöd angeguckt,
so, was haben die da unterm Arm?
Und dann sind wir halt quer durch Frankfurt gefahren.
Damals noch in die Kleierstraße,
da sind viele Rechenzentren.
Wir sind in die Kleierstraße gefahren,
und
mit der, mit der U-Bahn, das war, glaub ich, so
30 Minuten
US-Bahn fahren,
S-Bahn war es, S-Bahn war es, nicht, nicht U-Bahn.
Ne, ne, auch nicht S-Bahn, Schwachsinn, Straßenbahn war es.
Mit der Straßenbahn
30 Minuten quer durch
Frankfurt mit solchen Dingern, die sind nicht super
schwer, aber die ganze Zeit, die tragen sind's ja auch nicht so,
äh, nicht so leicht.
Zumindest, das eigentliche Problem war,
hat angefangen, als wir,
also, ja, also, ein Plate war
ungefähr Azubi-Jahresgehalt,
könnte man sagen.
Eher, eher
2-Jahres-Gehälter, also der Kram war
teuer.
Ja, so, und, zumindest,
das, eins, das, das große Problem kam
dann, als wir ausgestiegen sind.
Als wir ausgestiegen sind,
hat's angefangen zu regnen.
Und da mussten wir uns damals
die Plates unter die Jacke stecken.
Und da sind wir,
wie die, wie die, das sah
von, ich weiß nicht, das muss für die,
umstehenden Leute ausgesehen haben, als haben wir
irgendwelche schwere Bewaffnungen
unter der Jacke stecken, ja.
Also, wir hatten dann so, so richtig,
richtig Panzerplatte quasi
davor unter der Jacke. Sind dann, sind
dann da langgelaufen. Und am
Eingang hat dann die Security auch gemeint,
bei uns, wir sollen mal zeigen, was wir unter der Jacke
haben.
Was habt ihr denn da dabei,
Jungs?
Was?
Haben wir die Jacke auch
gemacht, haben gesagt, das ist ein Play,
also, du kommst ja in diese Rechenzentrum
nicht so, in diese Rechenzentrum nicht so einfach rein.
Du musst immer,
die haben nicht gelacht, nee, die haben die Jacke
aufgemacht und gesagt, wir müssen ins Rechenzentrum und gesagt,
ah ja, okay.
So, und
bevor du ins Rechenzentrum
rein kannst, du musst ja immer an die Anmeldung
gehen. Das sind ja meistens Locations,
die werden von einem, ja, Anbieter
betrieben und der hat dort mehrere Räume,
wo man sich einmieten kann.
Und
du musst es dann
halt zur Anmeldung, musst es sagen,
hier, ich bin der Max, ich will ins Rechenzentrum von
XY, so und so viel der Stock und wir
brauchen halt eine Karte.
Oder, wie es
früher noch war, beim Proventer, ein Schlüssel.
So.
Oder einen Token zum
an die, an die, äh,
ja. Ich glaube, damals war es ein Schlüssel
und ein Token. Man hat einen Schlüssel gebraucht
für das Gebäude und man hat einen Token gebraucht für den
Raum, irgendwie so war es. So ein elektronisches
Token zum Vorbeiziehen.
Und dann
musste man da rein,
dann haben die sich das erstmal angeguckt
und dann durfte man da hin.
Ja, das war, das war ein Erlebnis, da
irgendwie eine Stunde mit
Blades durch Frankfurt zu laufen.
Ja. Und der Scheiß war halt
wirklich teuer. Ja, Ticketsystem.
Outlook als Ticketsystem, okay, das ist
Paintschamp. Äh, das ist auch nicht
schlecht, Avi. Node.js,
JavaScript, top zum Einsteig.
Äh, zum Einsteig, Alter.
Das ist super zum Einsteigen, super zum
Anfangen, ja. JavaScript.
JavaScript, finde ich, ist eh die beste Sprache
zum Einstieg, weil an Frontend kommst du nicht
vorbei. Gut, mit Node.js kann man da auch anfangen,
ja. Aber an Frontend kommst du nicht vorbei.
Ein bisschen HTML, JavaScript,
CSS muss jeder können heutzutage
und es ist halt dementsprechend auch das Einfachste zum
Einsteigen. Man kann aber auch mit Node anfangen, warum nicht?
Dann lernst du gleich ein bisschen NPM
Package Management, wobei NPM
halt so ziemlich der Paintschampigste
Package Manager ist. Es wird nur noch
getoppt von C++-Header-Files rumkopieren.
Ja, aber zum Einstieg
nicht TypeScript. Zum Einstieg ist vollkommen okay,
direkt mit JavaScript anzufangen. Da braucht man nicht
noch zusätzlich was obendrauf.
Ähm, ausgeraubt
wurden wir nicht. Ganz im Ernst,
ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass der 0815
Frankfurt-Kriminelle
weiß, dass diese Dinger viel
wert sind. Und geschweige denn, was er damit
machen soll, wenn er sie gekauft, wenn er sie
ausgeraubt hat. Oh, das
ist auch nicht schlecht. Äh, ich weiß nicht,
welche das sind. Wie viel
Höheneinheiten die haben.
Gibt's keine Bilder daran.
Heißt die Dinger nicht
DL normalerweise?
Ich weiß nicht, hieß der auch HL?
Äh, dann keine Ahnung.
Ähm, ich dachte die Dinger hießen DL.
DL380 und so
war es immer die. Aber Moment, war das DEL?
Moment, jetzt blicke ich nicht mehr durch.
Ne, DL380
ist HP, ne?
Die
HP, ja.
Ja, das ist nicht so
ohne.
Wir mussten mal ein Playcenter einbauen.
Und so,
so, so ungefähr auf, auf
Brustebene, Brust, Brusthöhe.
Ähm, und dann hochheben
in die, in die Schienen.
Das war auch ganz toll.
Das sind acht, das war so eine Acht-Höheneinheiten-Kiste.
So was hier.
So ein Teil.
Baut so was mal ein. Das Zeug ist
abfuck schwer.
Also das Beste, was ihr machen könnt, komplett nackig.
Also komplett raus, Netzteil raus.
Ähm, Plates raus.
Alles raus, was geht. Und dann wiegt das immer noch
50 Kilo oder so.
Ach, Gachi-Buzz, Leute, genau.
Das war das Gegenteil von Gachi-Buzz.
Das war wirklich anstrengend.
Zeig mal, wie sehen die Dinger aus.
Na gut, 2010 ist auch schon ein bisschen länger her.
War das so ein Tower-Teil oder so?
Ja, ist auf jeden Fall, ist auf jeden Fall.
Gab's, also gerade früher gab's
richtig fette Kisten.
Heutzutage gibt's selten was
über diese, also über 4 HE
gibt's eigentlich so gut wie nie.
Die meisten sind 2 HE.
Hm, also
ich, ich glaube ich hab lange
keine richtig fetten,
selber mal gesehen.
Mal von Storage-Systemen aus, außen vor.
Aber 2010 ist ja auch schon,
ist ja auch schon ein bisschen her.
Ich rate jetzt einfach mal, ja.
Also wenn 80 das Geburtsjahr ist,
dann war's ja 2010 auch schon
eine Weile da am Start in der Richtung.
Ich bin ja auch 1984 geboren,
also ich war ja auch schon ein bisschen älter
als 2010.
Und da gab's halt noch fette Kisten.
Ich glaub, das kriegen die Leute heutzutage
gar nicht so mit.
Wenn, ähm, heutzutage alles,
das zusammengeklickt wird, so nach dem Motto,
ja, ich brauche einen neuen Server,
ja, geh mal in ESX und klick eine neue VM an.
Oder ja, geh mal in Azure und leg eine neue,
äh, leg eine neue Cloud-Kiste an.
Wir haben damals die Kiste,
wenn die einer haben wollte,
tatsächlich noch eingebaut
und ins Rechenzentrum rübergetragen.
Ja, haben wir nicht mehr.
Also wir haben keine Plates mehr.
Wir haben keine Plates mehr.
Wir haben auch keine Plates-Center mehr.
Ne, aber damals war's echt so.
Wenn irgendjemand gesagt hat, äh,
wir brauchen eine neue, wir brauchen einen neuen Server,
das ist nicht so gewesen,
dass du in irgendeinem Web-Interface angeklickt hast,
ich will einen neuen Server.
Die Jugend von, das ist, das ist so,
die kennen das nicht mehr.
Die können sich das nicht vorstellen.
Leute, wenn ihr heute eine VM haben wollt,
äh, wenn ihr heute einen Server haben wollt,
dann geht ihr zu irgendeinem Cloud-Anbieter,
sagt VM, VM, anklicken, next, next, next, fertig.
Das war damals nicht so.
Wenn damals einer einen Server haben wollte,
hat er angerufen bei uns,
hat gesagt, Leute, wir brauchen ein neues System,
äh, dann sind wir ins Lager
mit dem, mit dem Wagen,
ihr kennt, kennt sie vielleicht,
das sind diese Wagen, die, ähm,
die man nicht gescheit steuern kann,
weil sie die Lenkung irgendwie hinten haben,
total wirr, wie das ist,
und,
dann bist du ins Lager,
hast deinen Wagen voll gemacht,
ähm, bist, bist rüber,
über die Straße, geeiert,
ins Rechenzentrum,
hast Pech gehabt, weil der, weil der Gehweg
abschüssig war, dass das dann dir
vielleicht noch runtergerutscht ist, halb,
dann bist du, ja genau,
diese Dinger, ja, ja, dann bist du rübergelaufen,
ins Rechenzentrum,
bist rübergelaufen, bist in den Fahrstuhl,
bist hochgefahren, ähm,
hast die Rampe runtergeklappt,
dass du deinen Wagen hochschieben konntest,
dann hast du mit Hauruck
deine, deinen Wagen mit Server
die Rampe hochgeschoben, ins Rechenzentrum rein,
ähm,
dann hast du den abgeladen und hast den Kram eingebaut.
Also, wenn jemand morgens
gesagt hat, wir brauchen ein neues System,
und man wirklich gesagt hat,
ja, wir machen das jetzt gleich,
der hatte das, das hat, der hatte das,
was weiß ich, drei Stunden später oder so erst,
das hat schon ein bisschen gedauert,
ja, ein IBM, ein IBM
Mainframe haben wir immer noch, aber das hat, das hat
ein bisschen gedauert, dazu musstest du dann damals
nicht nur den Kram einbauen, du musstest erst mal
Schienen reinmachen, also musst du erst mal
richtige Stelle raussuchen, ja, eintragen, ähm,
Rackplatz frei, frei machen,
Schienen einbauen,
ähm, dafür musstest
du diese tollen, äh, Rack-
Klipse holen, ich weiß nicht, wie sie heißen,
Klip, Klips,
ne,
die da, meine ich, ich weiß nicht,
wie die Dinger heißen, da, die da,
musstest die da da holen, diese
Server-Rack-Klip-Nuts,
ja,
und da hast du dir auch gerne mal die Finger eingeklemmt
in diesen Dingern, Rack-Muttern,
ja, so heißt das anscheinend, Käfig-Muttern,
seh, der Chat, der Chat
kennt sich aus, da hast du dir diese Dinger geholt,
hast die erst mal rangeklipst,
dann musstest du die, ähm,
Schienen richtig einstellen,
da hast du die Server-Schienen reingemacht, aber, äh,
hast die Schienen rausgezogen, dann musstest
du irgendwie eine vollbestückte 2-HE-Kiste
erst mal, im Zweifelsfall so auf Brust- oder
Kopfhöhe heben und dann reinsetzen,
reinschieben, dann musst du den Kram
verkabeln hinten dran, und wenn
du den Kram hinten dran verkabelt hast, dann musstest du
nebenbei beim Netzwerk-Team anrufen, oder
wer auch immer damals zuständig war, oder man hat
selbst gemacht, hat gesagt, hier, Port XY,
wie sieht's denn aus, könnt ihr uns das, könnt ihr
uns das konfigurieren, da hast du 15 Minuten
gewartet, bis die ihre Netzwerk-
Config gemacht haben, dann hast du das angesteckt, dann sagst du,
okay, Link ist da, dann bist du in Speed,
Bios rein, vorher hast du hier noch diesen hässlichen
ähm, Monitorwagen
in den Gang gezogen vom
hinter dem Server, wo du danach
erst mal alle möglichen Krankheiten und
Erkältungen hattest, wenn du da zu lang gehockt hast,
ja,
nur vom Feinsten sag ich euch,
da hast du dich angestöpselt bis ins Bios,
hast die Management-IP-Adresse vergeben,
hast sie wieder irgendwo
eingetragen, ja, wenn du das
gemacht hast, hast du vielleicht dein KVM angeschlossen,
bisschen Technikraum nebendran,
und dann
gab's noch die ganz, dann gab's noch die ganz
Hardcore-Variante,
Datenbank-Server installieren, Datenbank-Server
wurden damals bei uns von CD installiert,
kein Witz,
Red Hat Enterprise Linux, 4 CDs,
4 CDs,
Enterprise Linux, und unsere
Datenbank-Leute damals, oder beziehungsweise
die Datenbank-Kunden
des Providers, wo ich gewesen bin,
die waren der Meinung, sie brauchen
eine Red Hat Vollinstallation für ihre
Datenbanken, das war kein Witz,
du hast die Datenbanken gestartet und es
hat dich erstmal einen Gnome angeguckt,
du hast erstmal einen Gnome-Login-Manager gehabt,
wenn du dich auf die Datenbanken connected hast,
also per Monitor,
Vollinstallation wollten die haben, und macht
mal ne Red Hat Vollinstallation mit CDs,
da sitzt der auch 45 Minuten
davor und guckt der Installation zu,
also
neuer Datenbank-Server, 3-4 Stunden,
also der halbe Tag war rum,
zwischendurch bist du nochmal aufs Essen gegangen, also
jetzt ohne Mist, Datenbanken einbauen,
patchen und installieren,
war ein Tagesjob,
also das,
okay, da gebe ich zu, waren etwas andere
Zeiten,
ich weine der Sache auch nicht nach, muss ich
ehrlich sagen, so Turnschuh-Administration
ist gut, dass es
das in dieser Form so
weit
verbreitet nicht mehr gibt,
heute ist es einfacher, heute hast du ein paar
ESX-Cluster,
machst ein paar VMs oder gehst
in die Cloud, machst ein paar VMs, aber irgendeiner
muss die Sachen heute auch noch im Rechenzentrum einbauen.
Nichtsdestotrotz,
war das gut zu
wissen,
ja, ist auch genug vom Krieg erzählt,
genau, das habe ich auch geschafft,
ja,
wir hatten es auch schon mal, dass die Server die Lüfter in die falsche
Richtung, die falsche Richtung hatten,
weil man die Lüfter rumdrehen musste oder den ganzen Server rumdrehen
musste und so komische Dinger,
jetzt rennt man von Tickets, ja, ja, okay,
es ist ein bisschen anders, ja,
aber früher war Turnschuh-Admin dann wirklich,
also ich habe, ich habe,
gerade während meiner Ausbildung habe ich sehr viel
Turnschuh-Admin gemacht, zumal die auch gerne
die Azubis in Technikräume geschickt haben,
die haben damals,
wir hatten damals, ähm,
bei, bei verschiedenen Kunden hatten wir
so Technikräume und
es war so, die Technikräume waren
halt mini, dass
sie halt Bürofläche hatten und
die haben immer die Azubis in die Technikräume
geschickt damals und die Technikräume waren wirklich
haaresträumend, ja, die Switche
hingen hochkant an der Wand und sowas,
also die waren nicht sonderlich, also nicht, dass man
denkt, da war genug Platz für den Rack,
in so einem Technikraum, das war wirklich
ganz schmale Abstellkammer,
da musstest du die Switche hochkant hängen, damit
sie überhaupt reingepasst haben, so,
zumindest haben die damals die Azubis da reingeschickt,
weil wir die einzigen Leute
waren im Team, die dünn
genug waren zur
damaligen Zeit,
wobei mittlerweile
würde ich vielleicht mit ganz
viel Bauch einziehen, jetzt nachdem ich jetzt abgenommen habe,
die letzten paar Monate wieder
durchpassen, ja, ähm,
weil wir so dünn waren und die einzigen
die durchgepasst haben, ohne, dass wir die halbe
Verkabelung mit runterreißen, ich meine
damals hatte ich, hab ich 70,
70, 75 Kilo oder so gewogen, da war das
kein Ding, bin ich,
da durchte mir nix,
ja, ok, so, jetzt habe
ich aber echt genug vom Kriech erzählt, jetzt gucken wir mal
weiter, wo sind wir stehen geblieben,
ähm, Call of,
eigentlich sind mir die Call of Duty Leaks egal,
außer, dass der aussieht, als hat er sich die Weisheitszähne
ziehen lassen,
wie viel hast du von deinem schwersten Stand abgenommen,
äh, 13, 1,5,
Kilo, jetzt, es ist jetzt ein bisschen
langsamer geworden, also ich hab mich
letztens, deswegen hab ich ja auch schon eine Weile auf
Twitter, auf Twitter kein Wagen
Update mehr gepostet,
es hat sich jetzt so eingependelt,
es geht immer so, bisschen minimal
geht das schon noch runter, aber nicht, jetzt nicht mehr so
krass wie, äh, ich zeig euch das
eine Woche später und ein Kilo ist weg, oder so,
na, so viel ist es, so krass ist es jetzt nicht,
neuer Zweitkanal,
ich mach ja nix,
ich esse ein bisschen
weniger fettig, ich
äh, bewege mich halt mehr,
ja, wie gesagt, ich esse ein bisschen weniger fettig
und ich bewege mich mehr, ich gehe jeden Tag
eineinhalb, zwei Stunden lau, äh,
wandern, nicht laufen, weil laufen denken
die meisten Leute joggen, ich gehe nicht joggen, ich gehe wirklich
laufen, durch den
Wald, jetzt nicht super langsam
oder so, aber auch nicht gejoggt,
und das bringt
tatsächlich was, wer hätte, warte,
wer hätte es gedacht, wer hätte es gedacht,
weniger Kalorien essen und
mehr bewegen führt zu weniger
Kilo, da hätte man ja überhaupt nicht dran
denken können, ja, wer hätte,
wer hätte da noch drauf kommen können, ja,
so, jetzt gucken wir mal in der FCAP weiter.
Joggen, Joggen, Joggen, Joggen, Joggen,
Nicht, mich nicht,
nicht,
übt
mich überhaupt nicht
Boah, Decades to come,
also, die, ist das jetzt,
also untertreiben wollen sie auf gar
keinen Fall, ja. Boah, De-
Decades to come, man könnte nicht einfach sagen, ja, das Spiel, also wir hoffen, dass das Spiel auch noch für ein paar Jahre relevant bleibt, aber Decades, das sind 10 mehrere Jahrzehnte, also entweder updaten die wirklich das Spiel durchgängig mit neuem Content und spielen vielleicht 10 Jahre noch welche, aber ganz im Ernst, also Decades to come ist vielleicht ein wenig optimistisch, ja.
Achso, ja gut, das ist die Serie in den nächsten, das kann ich mir nicht, wenn die Destiny 3 rausbringen und neue Teile und solche, klar, warum nicht, aber es hat sich für mich so angehört, als ist das das Destiny, was es jetzt gibt.
Der Destiny 1 ist noch online, aber es gibt halt nichts für.
Konnte man eigentlich seine Helden übernehmen aus Destiny 1 zu Destiny 2?
Doch, ist es, ist es.
An Alpha Playtest ist currently available, if you sign up for an account on the game's website.
It's one mission from the game's North African campaign and will be playable until the 19th.
Bloodhunt, the Vampire Battle...
Battle Royale is changing its update model.
Originally, the devs at Shark Mob intended on delivering a 12-week standard season with a battle pass of 100 levels.
Unfortunately, this model has prevented the developers from releasing key bug fixes and gameplay improvements quickly,
since major updates are built into seasonal launches rather than releasing as they're needed.
Instead of this seasonal model used by many of...
Spielt das? Spielt das überhaupt noch jemand?
Das ist so ein Game, wo ich die ganzen Battle Royale-Leute...
Irgendwie zwei Tage haben spielen sehen und dann hat's keiner mehr gespielt.
Ja, okay, doch, ein paar, aber nicht, nicht wirklich.
Bloodhunt's Competitors, it will revert to the classic monthly content update model.
Bugs and issues will be addressed continuously, starting with the summer update that launched this week.
Ja, also, ganz im Ernst, wie kommt man auf die Idee, Bugs und Sachen nicht continuously zu adressen?
Die Battle Passes being shortened and getting a price reduction to compensate.
Du kannst doch für wichtige Fixes nicht zwölf Wochen warten, was denken die sich denn?
...Match has also been added to the...
Schnellanzeigen haben wir uns erst letzte Woche angeguckt.
...Game to introduce the players to the Battle Royale's mechanics in a slightly more forgiving manner.
Developers at Crytek have decided to remove the current leaderboard system in place for Hunt Showdown.
According to them, the current leaderboard isn't aligned with their original vision.
It'll be removed from the game with update 1.9.
But the developers have clarified that a replacement system will be added...
...further down the line.
There's no exact time frame on when that'll happen, but Crytek...
Und warum remoufen sie das Leaderboard?
Weil da zu viele Cheater drin sind?
Oder, ich meine, irgendein Grund muss es noch haben?
Kannst du nicht einfach sagen, ja, wir machen das jetzt raus, weil Vision und so...
Die müssen wir ein bisschen besser begründen.
...assured players that they'll keep them updated.
And while players are pleased with the removal of the leaderboard,
some fans wish Crytek would go further and remove the KD statistics entirely.
Many argue that they have no place in Hunt Showdown.
Is das so?
In most competitive shooters, Hunt Showdown doesn't have a dedicated ranked mode.
It assigns you a general matchmaking rank based on...
Ist das, ist das so?
Wollen wirklich viele Leute KD entfernt haben?
...on your performance and puts you in lobbies with equally skilled players.
The game's current ranking system heavily favors your kill-to-death ratio.
And while this isn't really an issue at lower ranks,
the higher tiers seem to be more ripe with people using almost exclusively the best weapons in the game...
Ja, aber das ist doch immer so.
Das ist das, was zu meinem letzten Video passt.
Es wird nur noch geschwitzt als fuck.
Entspannt spielen kannst du nicht.
Was ich ehrlich gesagt doof finde, weil deswegen sollte es einen Rank-Modus geben
oder irgendwie einen Liga-Modus und halt Quick-Play.
Weil ich will ja oftmals sogar schwitzen im Spiel, aber dann halt im Rank-Modus.
...also bushcamping to just farm kills.
The game is intended to be more of an extraction royale than a deathmatch experience,
removing the leaderboard and placing a greater emphasis...
...on something like banishing boss monsters could help improve the general experience.
Star Citizen's developer Cloud Imperium Games just announced a major milestone.
It's amassed a total of 4 million registered accounts.
This year has seen insane growth with in-game events like Invictus and Free Fly Weeks...
...attracting tens of thousands of new players overnight.
The game is currently in a pre-release alpha state with core features and mechanics yet to be implemented.
...mit.
There's also the long-awaited Squadron 42 single-player campaign that has missed multiple deadlines.
Das kommt wahrscheinlich auch nicht raus.
Der Singleplayer sollte doch schon vor drei Jahren oder so rauskommen.
...starting to shape up into a real game with tons of content to play through.
PlayStation announced a new loyalty program called PlayStation Stars.
It'll begin later this year and will be free to sign up to.
Players in the program complete objectives in-game to earn points.
These points can be redeemed in the store or for other rewards.
Players can also earn digital collectibles.
These include figurines of memorable characters from your favorite games.
Platinum trophies are unique.
However, the first person worldwide to unlock a platinum trophy for a new game will get an exclusive one-time prize.
Es wäre richtig cool, wenn das nächste God of War auch mit PC direkt kommt.
Weil ich kaufe mir keine PS5 nur für ein Game.
New collectibles and awards will be added regularly.
PlayerUnknown's Battlegrounds latest update includes...
...a new map called Destin.
This is the first map released since the game went free to play earlier this year.
Destin is set in a city flooded by a massive hurricane,
giving a mix of rich vegetation in some areas and large cities and others.
The town also includes the tallest skyscraper in PUBG history.
Auf der PS4 spiele ich es bestimmt nicht.
Ich habe eine PS4, aber ich habe eine Release-PS4.
Das kannst du vergessen.
Das spiele ich bestimmt da nicht drauf.
Also entweder kommst du für einen PC oder ich spiele es halt nicht.
Oder ich warte.
Ich warte ein Jahr, bis es auf den PC kommt.
Devices called Ascenders have also been added to make traversing the buildings easier.
The map features new vehicles like the Pillar Car and new weapons like the MP9 SMG and the 012 Shotgun.
A game reviewer on Twitter says that the next Assassin's Creed title will be set in the Aztec Empire.
The rumor was immediately shot down by Bloomberg writer Jason Schreier,
who reiterated that the next game would be set in Baghdad.
According to him, the Assassin's Creed title...
...originally started as an expansion for Valhalla, but grew in scope to become its own game.
It's called Rift and will act as a filler until the multi-era Assassin's Creed game Infinity launches sometime next year.
Ja, da habe ich ja drauf gewartet.
20th Century Games has teamed up with VR-Dev-Studio Servios to create a new Aliens game.
The studio has promised fans an...
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, das letzte Assassin's Creed, was ich gespielt habe, war...
...Unity?
Ich glaube, Unity?
Das, was so mega verbuggt war zu Release.
Ich glaube, Unity war das.
Danach habe ich kein Assassin's Creed mehr gespielt.
Und die letzten haben mich auch nicht so angesprochen.
Wobei mich das Setting...
Wobei ich ehrlich gesagt die Settings cool fand, sowohl Ägypten als auch Griechenland.
Oder auch England und so jetzt.
Oder nee, was England?
Weiß gar nicht, Valhalla zum größten Teil gespielt, wahrscheinlich England.
Vom Setting her schon.
Aber was mich halt abgeschreckt hat...
...ist, dass das Spiel sah so komplett nach Arbeit aus.
An jeder Ecke musst du irgendeine Kiste looten.
Ich fand das bei Unity schon merkwürdig, dass du Online-only-Kisten hattest und sowas.
Wenn du deinen Account nicht verknüpft hast, gab es keine Kisten an manchen Stellen und so.
...set between the first and second Alien movies.
The game is being built using Unreal Engine 5, so it certainly has the potential to look fantastic.
More details will be revealed next week.
During the San Diego Comic Con.
John Riccitello, the current CEO of Unity and the former CEO of EA...
Oh ja, das habe ich mitgekriegt.
Das ist auch ein schwachs... Alter, was ein Dummschwätzer, ey.
...made a bold statement this week.
Was ein Dummschwätzer, Alter.
...Riccitello stated that if game developers aren't designing their games with monetization in mind, then they're idiots.
This was met with, of course, massive...
Man darf nicht vergessen, das ist ein Game Engine Hersteller.
Ich weiß nicht, was die treiben.
Warum wollen die ihre Entwickler abfacken?
Was ist das für ein Volldepp, Alter?
Okay, ich weiß, was das für ein Volldepp ist.
Der war vorher bei EA und hat's verkackt und ist jetzt bei Unity.
Kein Witz, guck nach, das ist wirklich so.
Ähm, ich kann... Ich versteh's nicht.
...from devs and players alike, but it was particularly harmful to the indie space,
which typically struggles with funding from the get-go.
And while he followed up by saying that devs need to adapt to the changing...
Die Source-Con von gestern gibt es nicht online, nee.
Das waren ja nur 80 Zeilen Go.
Easy, auch noch.
...gaming landscape, the backlash only continued.
Riccitella's statement came hot off the heels of Unity announcing layoffs for 263 employees,
as well as a merger with mobile adware company Ironsource.
That company has...
Nicht nur Adware, das sind ja auch die, die angeblich genau Malware verbreitet haben.
Musst du dir das mal vorstellen.
Ein Game Engine Anbieter kauft...
Oder was heißt kauft?
Merged mit einem anderen Anbieter.
Für, äh, Analytics und Adware und wohl auch Sachen, die als Malware eingestuft sind.
Und jetzt haben sie halt das Problem, also jetzt, was ich mich zumindest fragen würde als Entwickler,
ist der Scheiß in meinem Game drin.
Was ich ja persönlich an Unreal nicht mag, ist, dass es C++ ist,
was aber für mich egal ist, weil ich keine Games entwickle.
...Software, das wie Malware funktioniert.
Wenn du jemals ein bisschen Software auf deinem PC installiert hast,
und die Installation...
Ja!
...Included a bunch of random antivirus software or browser extensions,
that's what InstallCore does.
Before we move on to our final story of the day,
let us know in the comments what you think about the Battlefield 3 Reality Mod.
Does the Milsim-Style suit the Battlefield series?
Ja! Gucken wir uns. Gucken wir uns. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich mir heute Abend im Stream angucke, aber vielleicht.
If you haven't subscribed yet, be sure to hit that sub-button,
as it's a really good way to support the channel.
That sub-button hitten wir.
Skate developer FullCircle...
Ich kann den nicht hitten, weil ich bin nicht eingeloggt.
...hosted a behind-the-scenes showcase this week.
They revealed that the new Skate game would be a free-to-play live-service title
with cosmetic microtransactions.
The devs intend for Skate to be a community-driven game
with a constantly evolving world.
Pre-alpha gameplay was shown off,
and the devs clarified that things are still very early in development,
though different community members are being taken for feedback sessions
as they get a chance to try out this early build.
And that wraps it up for today's episode of This Week in Gaming.
As always, guys, thank you so much for watching,
and I'll catch you next time.
See you!
Wir können uns den Reality-Mod-Trailer noch kurz angucken.
Also aktuell sieht es ja aus wie Battlefield 3, nur ohne HUD.
Und es passiert nix.
Aber okay, es ist halt realistisch.
Da passiert auch nicht laufend was.
Es scheinen Vanilla-Maps zu sein, wenn ich mir das so angucke.
Keine neuen Maps.
Aber die Maps, gerade die LC-Maps, sind ja noch gar nicht irgendwie großartig...
Also die wurden ja nicht so viel gespielt.
Was das für eine Map ist, weiß ich beispielsweise gar nicht.
Ja, das ist natürlich cool,
dass Battlefield 3 schon ordentliche Zerstörungen...
hatte.
Die Musik passt nicht wirklich zu dem, was passiert, oder?
Können wir mal einen No-Map...
Erstmal müssen wir einen Kubernetes-Stream machen.
Kubernetes.
Dass man fünf Stunden am Laufen ist...
Ich denke, das hier wird nicht so krass wie in Arma,
aber auch nicht wie in Battlefield,
so reinrennen, fünf bis zehn Leute umballern und sterben und respawnen.
So wird's wahrscheinlich nicht sein.
Hat Battlefield 3 überhaupt dedicated Server?
Ja.
Mit Venice hast du sogar Server, die du selbst hosten kannst.
Tja.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so ist.
Bin ich mal gespannt, was dabei rauskommt.
TheRealAgentSmith hat abonniert.
25 Monate.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Massive Subscription.
So, was gucken wir uns denn jetzt an?
Nein.
Was Linux-Fanboy reviews macOS.
Äh, okay.
Warum nicht?
DentuDev, dankeschön für den Sub.
Ein Linux-Fanboy reviewed macOS.
MacOS feels old.
Ich fiele mich auch old.
Okay, zeigt mal her.
Moin.
Hey everyone, this is Nick.
And today I'm gonna take a look at macOS.
But from the viewpoint of somebody who's been daily driving Linux for the past five years.
Now, macOS has often been taken as the master reference for UX, UI and generally is considered super simple...
Naja, gut.
Da kann man sich drüber streiten, was die auf jeden Fall besser machen als Windows und was die auch besser machen als Windows.
Und was die auch besser machen als Linux ist, dass ihre Anwendungen einheitlich sind und sie eine ordentliche, einheitliche Design-Philosophie haben und ein ordentlich einheitliches Design-Framework haben für ihr System.
Nicht so wie Windows, wo du fünf verschiedene Sachen hast.
Nicht so wie Linux, wo es gar nichts wirklich Offizielles gibt und auch hundert verschiedene Sachen.
Das machen die tatsächlich gut.
Alles setzt sich auch nicht durch. Keine Ahnung, ob irgendein Spiel jemals auf Metal basiert ist.
Wahrscheinlich, aber mir fällt keins ein.
Warum sollte man das machen?
Hat Unity jemals ein Metal-Backend gehabt?
Ich... keine Ahnung.
Aber zumindest ist Metal jetzt nicht so super verbreitet gewesen.
...easy to use, although a little bit limited.
So we're going to take a look at how it works with all the bad faith and all the unjustified criticism that I'm probably going to get...
Ich bin froh, dass wir seine Brustbehaarung sehen in dem Video.
...accused of.
What I can't be accused of though is not telling you about today's sponsor, a fantastic open source...
Alter! Keine 36 Sekunden im Video und schon Sellout, Alter!
...office suite for Linux.
This video is on Reddit.
But first, a warning, I won't be running the very latest version of Mac OS, because I only own an old Intel Xeon cheese grater...
Big Sur! Wann kam denn Big Sur raus?
Nicht, dass das jetzt irgendwie was ist, was sonst wann...
Okay, zwei Jahre, das ist okay, damit sich nicht so viel geändert haben.
...Mac Pro, that was supposed to stop getting updates a while ago.
Aber es heißt ja eigentlich Big Sur, heißt es ja.
I never found the time to try and update it to Monterey, so some things might not look exactly like you want them to.
Still, Monterey doesn't fundamentally change the experience, apart from the new Safari tab bar, the ability to move your mouse pointer and keyboard seamlessly between multiple devices...
Ich baue kurz vor. So, Desktop.
...on to the desktop itself, the much vaunted Mac OS experience. Let's see how it holds up.
You get a top bar and a bottom dock, a layout that's now really common and easily replicated on...
Also man muss ja sagen, gerade Gnome hat sich sehr stark inspirieren lassen von Mac OS.
Guckt euch den Applications... den Application... wie heißt das nicht, Dock... Launcher an, unter Gnome.
Und guckt euch den Finder-Dings hier an unter Mac OS, also...
Das sieht ein bisschen anders aus, aber es hat schon enorme Ähnlichkeiten, ja.
Any Linux Desktop.
Mac OS goes for the global menu, which I like.
If I have to have a menu bar, I would rather it used up the exact same spot on the top of the screen, rather than have to hunt for the menu position on each window.
I know not everyone enjoys that, but I always found it was the best solution if you had to use menu bars.
The dock itself just hosts open applications and open windows for apps that aren't in the dock.
Plus it has the trash can, recent applications and a few nice features.
You can minimize your windows to the apps icon, you can add folders for quick access to various files, or even to your applications if you add your apps folder to it.
You can change the minimize effect used, automatically hide the dock, and you can move it to any screen edge, except the top one.
Moment, was für'n'n Ding... Sekunde...
Raven... das klappt doch hinten und vorne nicht, was soll das sein?
Ein BSD Desktop auch noch, okay, da kannst du davon ausgehen, dann wird's...
Ja, okay, vielleicht von der Optik her.
Aber...
Ja, ich mein, okay, immerhin, es ist der gleiche Unterbau wie macOS, es passt mit BSD schon, ist schon irgendwie sinnvoll, aber nee, das glaub ich nicht, dass da irgendwas sinnvolles rauskommt.
Keine Ahnung, würd mich wirklich wundern, wenn da irgendwas sinnvolles... aber mal schauen, ja.
Take that, Windows Taskbar.
It also has one very annoying limitation.
You cannot minimize an app by clicking on its icon, which is...
Das ist nicht schlimm.
Ich als Tiling-Window-Manager-User minimiere eh nix.
Very, very frustrating.
Clicking on the app's icon is much easier...
Aber es ist halt kein Tiling-Desktop.
Das heißt, da muss man schon was minimieren.
...target than that super small orange stoplight thing in the corner of the window.
The desktop holds icons.
By default only your disk drives, but you can store anything you want there.
With a nice feature, the ability to automatically stack files by file type.
This means that even if you want to make a mess over your wallpaper,
that mess can still be relatively organized and usable,
instead of being a huge creep of files and folders that you will never be able to sort through.
Was haben die alle immer mit aufgeräumten Desktops? Ich versteh das gar nicht.
Der beste Desktop ist ein Desktop, der benutzt wird.
Versteh ich nicht.
Ein Desktop deutlich besser.
The top bar also has the Apple menu for quick access to system functions,
like rebooting, shutting down, the system preferences and more.
And you get a clock and notification tray icons, which are less a problem on macOS,
because they have a well-defined API for it,
and developers tend to care about how things look on macOS.
So you rarely have a weird riot of colors, shapes and sizes up there.
Unlike what you would find in the system tray on Windows or on most Linux desktops.
Seriously, use monochrome icons, please.
You also have a nice little control center with quick access...
Ich find, das machen die unter macOS tatsächlich gut.
Ich mein, guckt euch mal im Vergleich die Windows-Taskleiste an.
Also, wobei Taskleiste kannst du es ja nicht nennen.
Das ist ja hier diese Macbar, unten ist ja die tatsächlich aufgesplittet.
Aber ich find, das machen die gut.
Das ist, das verhält sich auch so, wie ich es irgendwie erwarten würde.
... access toggles that you can drag and drop in the top bar
to always get a look at them if you don't want them hidden in a submenu.
Clicking on the time brings the notifications and widgets.
Desktop notifications are something I very rarely use.
Ja, widgets brauch ich nicht. Ja, ich auch nicht.
Ganz ehrlich, widgets sind komplett useless.
Genauso wie, nee, ach, wir sind ja nicht mehr bei Windows 11.
Genauso wie diese komischen Windows-11-Widgets, die wird auch niemand verwenden.
Auch wenn sie jetzt die Namen, beautiful widgets, oder was haben sie bei der Präsentation erzählt?
Beautiful, new, blazingly fast, innovative widget system.
It's so beautiful und so, ja, Windows-Präsentation.
... something I very rarely use.
And I also have literally no use for widgets in there.
But for people who want them, this is a very nice implementation.
It looks pretty and it can be pretty useful, I guess.
Generally, the desktop on macOS looks good.
It's pretty, it's simple, it's efficient.
And while it hasn't really changed much in the past 10 years, it's still fine.
PCom habe ich im Hintergrund laufen, ja, aber nur um Transparenz ordentlich zu haben.
... took some inspiration from it in GNOME and KDE, and that's also fine.
In terms of options and look and feel, you find a light or dark mode with an auto switch, depending on the time of day,
and accent colors, including one that is based on the dominant color of your wallpaper.
Nothing very complicated here.
Das Schöne ist, dadurch, dass die Sachen unter Mac relativ einheitlich sind, wenn du da dark mode einschaltest,
dann ist es auch wirklich eingeschaltet.
Und nicht wie bei Windows, bei manchen Sachen ist es da und bei ganz vielen ist es nicht da.
... use themes or change how the desktop works.
It's a default experience with a few locks options.
You also can't really change the default file manager, although you can change the default browser easily,
and the default apps for various file types.
It's definitely not as powerful as our Linux desktops,
which offer a lot more customization out of the box on KDE
and a lot more options with extensions.
Finally, to run applications, you either launch them from the dock,
or you have a full-screen app grid with search that works pretty much like the GNOME app grid.
Ich meine, guckt euch das an und guckt euch den GNOME Launcher an.
Also wenn das nicht voneinander inspiriert ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Das könnte eins zu eins der GNOME Launcher sein.
It's not bad, but it's not integrated with the multitasking view, which we'll talk about later.
So you can't just drag apps from the launcher to a virtual desktop to open them.
You can rearrange them, though, into folders or change their order.
Not bad, but also not the best implementation of an apps grid that I've seen.
GNOME beats that handily.
Finally, you get the excellent Spotlight.
Nee, das ist nicht die Schuld der Programmierer.
Das ist die Schuld von Microsoft, dass Microsoft seit 20 Jahren oder so
kein gescheites Desktop-Framework mehr rausgebracht hat.
Und es ist auch die Schuld von Microsoft, dass du UWB machst.
Ja, natürlich kannst du sagen, ja, warum sind das noch nicht alle auf UWP,
aber viele sagen, ja kannst du nicht in UWP machen,
mach einfach ein ordentliches Screenshot Tool zum Beispiel in UWP.
Mach einfach ein ordentliches Screenshot Tool zum Beispiel in UWP.
Da ist Microsoft dran schuld.
Bei Apple funktioniert das doch genau aus dem Grund.
Apple gibt eine einheitliche Designrichtlinie
Und Apple stellt die passenden,
YET ER NECKặcER
Und zwar DIE ofzielle
Und zwar DIE ofcielle
Und zwar DIE offzielle
api dafür zur verfügung so was zu implementieren und dann funktioniert und windows ist so ein
mischmasch aus teilweise noch windows forms wpf manche elektron anwendungen dann irgendwie manche
sind uwp anwendungen es ist halt kompletter mischmasch jetzt sind windows forms anwendungen
dann unter unter windows forms anwendungen haben wir auch kein darkmode einfach
oder guck dir obs an oder guck dir obs an obs hat nen darkmode aber der switcht sich nicht mit
windows oder so oder oder hin und her ja das ist tatsächlich cool der die diese diese wie nennt
sich das unter mac ist das der finder? spotlight ist das genau
der spotlight ist das glaube ich unter mac da können die sich hier bei dieser windows suche
echt was von abschneiden die windows suche ist absoluter müll find gar nix null komplett für
den arsch
gibt es ein linux wo dark light mode switch richtig
funktioniert?
nö du kriegst vielleicht du kannst vielleicht so was verwenden wie wie heißt diese china
distribution deep in oder elementary oder sonst was die haben das und da funktioniert das auch
aber nur wenn du exakt die vor installierten apps verwendest sobald du dir was zusätzliches
installiert funktioniert schon wieder nicht ich glaube ich habe meine pi com config im github
irgendwo da die ist relativ
übersichtlich und so starte ich... das war's mehr mache ich nicht
Why not make it more visible?
now on to the weakest point of mac Ole window management window management on mac coming from
linux even form of default windows manager is and
also ich habe ja schon immer anfälle bekommen wenn die buttons auf der linken seite anstatt
auf der rechten seite sind
also ich habe ja schon immer anfälle bekommen wenn die buttons auf der linken seite anstatt auf der rechten seite sind её Titelmanager oder nicht qualidade Otherwise problems often happen whenever the buttons on the left side are on the right side instead of the right side.
Mag jemand von euch, Leute, was sagt ihr?
Diese schließen Button links oben oder rechts oben?
Ich kann links oben nicht ab.
Ja, letztendlich ist es natürlich Gewöhnungssache, das stimmt schon.
Das ist auch eine Sache, die mich persönlich an macOS ein bisschen nervt.
Du hast so viele Animationen.
Ich meine, hey, es sieht cool aus, ja, ich sage da gar nichts dagegen.
Guck, wenn man jetzt hier diesen...
Das ist mir aber zu lang.
Und mal ganz davon abgesehen, ich minimiere ja gar keine Anwendung.
Also, was ich mache ist, ja...
Ist ja schon oft genug gesehen.
Ich switch einfach den Desktop.
So, hier Browser, hier Terminal, hier IDE.
Hier sonst was.
Da wird überhaupt nichts minimiert.
Kann man die aktivieren? Ja, das ist ja auch das Mindeste.
Aber wie lange das dauert? Das braucht ja fast eine halbe Sekunde bis das Fenster wieder da ist.
So that makes it alright.
No, no it doesn't. It's still terrible.
Then there's the Maximize-Button, which doesn't really maximize.
Äh, wieso? Macht's doch.
Ja, okay.
Sag mal so, das ist ja unter Windows auch so, ne?
Die Bar hast du ja oben weiterhin.
Ähm, gut.
Unter Linux ist es halt so, wenn ich Ctrl-F mache, gerade beim Browser,
dann blendet er halt alles aus.
Dann habe ich halt wirklich...
Fullscreen ist halt da auch wirklich Fullscreen.
So.
And to get them back, you have to hover over the top or bottom of the screen.
Not great.
If you press the Alt-Key and then click on the green button,
then your window will not maximize or go fullscreen.
It will just expand to fit as much of the content as it can.
Which, again, could be useful, but not hidden behind a shortcut that's never explained.
There is no way I could find to maximize a window while not going fullscreen.
Which really, really sucks.
Like, maximizing is...
A basic thing to want to do with your windows, without them going completely fullscreen.
It just feels weird and unsure...
Alternativ drückt man den Browser einfach F11 und es ist Fullscreen.
There's an arcane shortcut that you can do with Shift-Alt and clicking on the green button.
Ey, F11 drücken einfach.
But it's not explained and it definitely should be the default behavior.
Then there's the tiling.
You can't just drag a window to an edge of the screen to tile it.
Ach, das geht nicht?
You have to long press the green button to access a small submenu
that lets you pick an edge to tile the window.
Except it doesn't do just that.
Okay, da würde ich im Leben nicht drauf kommen, dass man so teilt.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, ich benutze Tiling unter Windows auch nicht,
sondern, äh, ich benutze es eigentlich nur unter Linux und damit im Tiling-Window-Manager, wo alles geteilt ist.
...forces you to pick another window to tile on the other half.
If you didn't want to have two tiled windows side by side, you're out of luck.
Your window will not stay tiled.
Echt nicht?
Ja, das ist doof.
Tile all three-thirds of the screen.
You can't even have a window stuck on an edge, and floating windows on the other side.
Okay, das ist tatsächlich doof.
Aber immerhin eine coole switch-Animation!
Weird unexplained keyboard shortcut that lets you do that, but I couldn't find it.
Why is MacOS at least five years behind in that regard?
Like, no drag to tile is bad enough.
No maximise is stupid.
But also not letting you tile a window and having floating windows on the other side also makes no sense.
Das heißt schon was.
Ja, den haben sie sich ja damals sogar schon unter Compets geklaut, falls noch jemand Compets kennt.
Da hattest du auch so ein Expose-View.
Wie gesagt, das hat sich Compets damals schon geklaut.
Leute, ich sag euch, die Zeit, wo Compets so richtig angesagt war, war die geilste Linux-Desktop-Zeit.
Das war genauso wenig Jahr das Linux-Desktop so wie heute, aber es war wenigstens irgendwie spannend.
Wenn du Fenster hattest, die abgefackelt sind oder irgendwie einen Würfel, der sich gedreht hat, Compets war einfach pock.
Das wirkt auf mich so...
Okay.
Als geht ihm der Punkt wirklich auf den Sack.
Das ist wirklich ein riesen Vorteil versus Windows.
Ich meine, Windows hat jetzt auch diesen hässlichen App-Store.
Nur, dass da irgendwie kaum was drin ist und der App-Store halt...
Leute, ich muss euch von meinem neuesten Windows-App-Store-Abenteuern erzählen.
Und zwar, ich habe mir einen Film gekauft oder eine Serien-Episode tatsächlich über den Windows-Store.
Weil der Windows-Store der einzige Store war, der die aktuelle Folge der Woche hatte.
Und ich habe mir das gekauft.
Das ging ganz gut, weil das ist mein alter Xbox-Account mit PayPal.
Angerichtet und so.
Und hat auch nur 2,99 Euro gekostet.
Alles okay.
Alles gut.
Habe ich gekauft.
Und ich mache das Ding an.
Und auf einmal, mein Kopf platzt, ey.
Das Ding hat einfach maximale Lautstärke.
Komplette, ähm...
Wie heißt das auf Deutsch?
Stellt euch den Battlefield 2042 Soundtrack vor.
Auf maximaler Lautstärke.
Also, das Ding ist irgendwie mit meinem Audio-Output nicht klargekommen.
Das hat einfach gemacht...
Und das in maximaler Lautstärke.
Leute, mir ist mein Kopf fast geplatzt.
Hab ich mir gedacht, alter, fuck.
Hab ich Kopfhörer...
Und ich hatte den Windows-Sound auf 30%, ja?
Das war maximale Lautstärke.
So, und dann habe ich mein Kopfhörer abgezogen und nochmal angemacht.
Das war wieder so.
Und ich musste dann ernsthaft erst folgendes machen.
Ich musste auf Sound gehen.
Playback.
Ähm, Digital Audio.
Advanced.
Und musste dieses Häkchen hier wegmachen.
Nachdem ich dieses Häkchen hier weggemacht hatte.
Dann ging's.
Nö, nö, Audio-Codec war alles drauf.
Der hatte irgendwie Probleme gehabt mit dem Abspielen.
Ich weiß nicht.
Das war ja auch dieser komische Windows-Bild-in-Media-Player.
Also dieses Ding hier.
Nicht der Windows-Media-Player.
Der Video-Playback-Player.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man den standardmäßig aufmacht.
Wie macht man den überhaupt auf?
Ich meine nicht den Windows-Media-Player.
Die, die, diese Player-App.
Ja.
Ähm.
Ja, es kann sein, dass es vielleicht irgendwie...
Ja, aber dann soll das Ding eine Fehlermeldung liefern und nicht einfach dir das Ohr kaputt machen.
Komplett unsinniger Kack, Alter.
...on a not so well-stocked App-Selection.
Contrary to iOS, you can't find everything in there.
For example, VLC-Apps.
VLC isn't.
LibreOffice also isn't.
Although there is a paid version in there, that's not...
Na gut, dass LibreOffice nicht im Apple-App-Store ist, wundert mich jetzt persönlich nicht.
Wie sieht das eigentlich mit Windows-App-Store aus?
Ist da LibreOffice drinne?
Was findest'n da für'n Scheiß?
Die Kohle.
Die Kohle-Office-Suite.
Mhm.
Genau die.
Die will ich bestimmt haben.
Die Kohle-Office-Suite.
Die sieht genauso aus, wie das, was ich haben will.
Moment.
Das ist LibreOffice.
Das ist ein China-Chinesen-LibreOffice-Fork.
Die Chinesen, Alter.
CoolOffice.
Das ist...
Das ist LibreOffice...
...aus China geforkt, Mann.
Boah, ist das schlecht, Alter.
Ach nee, sie sagen ja sogar schon.
CoolOffice-Suite is modified from open source project.
Okay.
Oh Mann, Alter.
Was'n Schrott.
Oh, was'n Schrott.
Warum is'n so was da überhaupt drinne?
Es gibt Reviews, aber es gibt doch keine Reviews, oder wie?
Guck mal.
Hier...
Hier gibt es eindeutig Reviews.
See all.
Es gibt keine Reviews.
Äh, hä?
Wait...
Näh.
Mein Gott, dieser Store ist so beschitzen, Alter.
Was...
Was ist mit Microsoft los?
Die Nebula-Office-Suite.
Ist das auch irgendein...
Open-Office-Fake?
Keine Ahnung.
Nee.
Ist das irgendein Open-Office-Fake?
Keine Ahnung.
So ein Rotz, Alter.
Naja, also der Windows Store ist da wirklich richtiger Müll.
Der Apple Store ist da deutlich besser.
Und ich sage euch ganz ehrlich,
Package Management unter Linux,
so diese Philosophie dahinter,
finde ich von allen am besten.
Der Vorteil von Apple ist halt,
dass du dir da auch kommerzielle Anwendungen drüber kaufen kannst,
die dann aktuell gehalten werden
und die sich easy kaufen lassen.
Dafür ist es natürlich gut, ja.
Aber es gibt ja immer noch Brew oder Homebrew für macOS,
zum Installieren von anderen Tools.
Erstmal Word installieren.
Wobei, ich verwende bestimmt viele Word unter Mac,
weil viele Leute auch Docx-Dokumente und sowas rumschicken.
Doch, doch, es gibt ein Package Management Manager unter Windows,
der ist aber noch ein bisschen,
ja, unfertig.
But who am I kidding?
Mac-Users don't use these apps.
They have a plethora of applications,
developed just for their OS.
And that follows their systems conventions to the letter.
So for that...
Hat der im Hintergrund die Mario 64-Musik aus dem Schloss?
...store is a good starting point.
We could even learn a thing or two
about how they present apps.
They have editorial content,
presenting stuff users might need,
by type of activity.
They present the most used and downloaded,
downloaded apps first.
Ja, aber wen juckt der App Store?
Head over to the Gaming Category in Discord.
Die haben Gaming Category,
die haben Gaming auf macOS?
...Or Organome Software.
You should see Steam first,
like it's the first thing that people are going to...
Warte, warte, das wird man im App Store nicht sehen.
Warum sollte Apple im App Store eine fremde Plattform bewerben?
Das kannst du vergessen.
...in terms of gaming.
But it's not there.
Ja.
That's stupid.
Das wundert mich nicht.
...on the Mac App Store, Steam is also not present right...
...when you open the gaming tab.
Wie ist es eigentlich unter im Windows Store?
Nö.
Alter, was ein Schrott.
Also der Windows Store ist wirklich Paintschamp extrem.
Still, I really like the fact that they have small listicles
that present one thing you might want to do with your computer
and present apps that are suited for that purpose.
Listicles.
It would be amazing to also have that on Linux
to help people discover alternatives
to the things they are used to on Windows or Mac.
It would also reduce the need to make...
videos for best apps for this thing
or best apps for doing that.
But that also would reduce my income.
So I guess it's for the best.
You get a user account here, of course,
so things you bought are kept ready for you to reinstall.
Except if the developer decided not to update
for your version of Mac OS.
In that case you're boned and you lost your money.
Ja, das ist ja unter allen Betriebssystemen so.
Ja, wenn das Ding irgendwelche Abhängigkeiten hat
und die gibt es nicht für dein aktuelles System,
dann hast du gelebt.
Pages are basically identical to...
what we now have on Discover or GNOME Software.
They are good, legible and useful
and you can install in one click.
Basically our App Store experience is pretty close on Linux
to what Mac OS offers.
Except we lack the ability to buy apps...
Such mal nach Clipchamp, ich weiß, dass es das gibt.
Dass es das gibt.
Da wird ja öfters im Chat gefragt, ob das von mir ist.
We don't have App Bundles
and we can't really restore purchases or downloads
that we already might have done on another computer
or another distribution.
Flathub Developers are working on the ability to pay for apps...
Flathub.
...if developers choose to...
Was kommt als nächstes?
Der Snap App Store.
...and they're working on user accounts that would let you re-download stuff.
Maybe they'll interface with what Elementor iOS does,
so the two solutions might work better together.
If you can't find what you're looking for on the store,
then you can still resort to the hunt online for a downloadable app solution.
What you get in the process is a DMG file, which is a disk image.
Ja gut, das ist ja das Gleiche wie unter Windows.
App runterladen und...
...installieren.
Gut, unter macOS zieht man die Dinger dann in Applications.
To install your application, you have to open the DMG file...
Ja.
...and then drag the app...
Also viel einfacher geht's doch nicht, oder?
...in a single file to your applications folder.
It sounds simple...
Was PCOM geht jetzt bei dir, Pog?
...on paper, and most DMG files have some kind of visual explanation
to let users know they need to drag the app into the folder.
The issue here is that I've met an incredible number of people
who never understood that.
Naja, das musst du dir einmal merken und dann geht's.
They opened the app from the DMG image,
which means it works read-only in most cases
and never saves any preference.
This is not a good way to install applications.
Again, on paper it sounds like a super simple...
Ja, das musst du dir einmal merken. So wild finde ich das jetzt nicht.
...drag the app to the apps folder and it's all installed,
added to your menu and whatever.
Except a lot of people are just not used...
...not used at all...
Ja, dann müssen sie das einmal lernen.
Also, das dürfte doch machbar sein.
...and they just don't understand it.
Also, wer es nicht versteht, ein Icon von links nach rechts
zwei Zentimeter zu tracken und droppen, dem ist wahrscheinlich nicht mehr zu helfen.
...it's simpler. You open the DMG file, you get a pop-up telling you
we're gonna copy this app to your apps folder.
Are you okay with that? Yes or no?
And if you say yes, boom, everything gets downloaded in the right folder
and the DMG file is deleted. Boom, you're done.
Of course, there's also the weird security gate,
the housekeeping that macOS is doing.
Showing pop-ups to let you know the app is signed by a certain developer,
would you really want to run that,
or sometimes just refusing to run it at all
until you give it permission in the system settings.
I understand the reasoning, but again, the implementation is terrible and convoluted.
Still, if you can find what you're looking for in the Mac App Store,
then the experience is smooth as hell and super easy.
If you can't, a lot of people will just pick up on the drag the app to the apps folder
and everything will work nicely and a lot of others will just get confused,
run the apps from the DMG and then wonder why nothing works like it's supposed to.
So, macOS isn't a bad operating system.
Its conventions are old but work well.
A top bar and a dock is a good combo.
The global menu is a good solution for menu bars.
It has a nice store to install apps, it has a few look and feel options,
and you can extend it with a few third-party utilities to better handle its shortcomings.
But it also shows its A.
Badly in some ways.
Window management is really, really bad.
Okay, da hat er mich tatsächlich überzeugt, das sah wirklich ziemlich hakelig aus.
To minimize a window with a click on the dock is annoying.
Not asking you which window you want to restore when clicking on an apps icon is stupid.
No tiling and no real maximize button means that you'll have to resize windows manually all the time
or buy a third-party utility.
Mission control is good on paper, but it doesn't really work well
if you want to quickly swap windows to different virtual desktops.
Opening apps isn't that complex with Launchpad or Spotlight,
but there is no easy way to set up your environment.
Gibt es einen Stream, wo du Archiv Wooplos gebaut hast?
Nee, weil das habe ich nicht gebaut.
Das hat da Serious Max gebaut.
Ich weiß nicht, ob er es alleine gebaut hat.
Deswegen sage ich mal, eher plus Mods eventuell haben das gebaut.
... by dragging apps to virtual desktops, for example.
All in all, the feeling I get when using macOS
is that of a system that has evolved by adding features on top of each other,
but that were never designed to work together at all.
All these features are isolated, and I feel that...
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das so sagen kann.
Ich finde, es ist immer noch mehr aus einem Guss als Windows
und es ist sicherlich auch mehr aus einem Guss als Linux.
... in the same vein, Gnome does things a lot better.
You have one single overview for apps, for windows, for search, for virtual desktops,
and it all makes it a lot easier.
You just drag your app icons to virtual desktops.
You just drag windows from one virtual desktop to another.
Das stimmt. Das stimmt. Virtual desktop handling.
Oder aber man benutzt einen tiling window manager und macht sich um so Sachen keine Gedanken.
It's just better integrated and it feels smoother and easier to use, honestly.
Apart from that, Apple obviously still does the store thing better than what we do on Linux.
Not ethically or in terms of monopolistic practices, although they don't really have a monopoly on Linux.
But in terms of how apps are presented, featured and explained, they're really good.
We could learn a thing or two here.
Of course, the sync capabilities and integration with other Apple devices can't be beat.
We don't have a Linux ecosystem to do all that.
But with KDE Connect and the Nextcloud Server, you're really not that far off.
It just lacks the simple, easy, single...
Bei Mac ist es halt so, es funktioniert alles wunderbar, solange du halt in diesem Mac OS Apple Ökosystem drinne bist.
So.
Sobald du ein bisschen was abweichendes machst, wird's halt schon eklig.
Habt ihr mal beispielsweise versucht, unter Linux euer Mac, äh, nicht euer Mac, euer iPhone zu synchen?
Okay, nennen wir es nicht synchen.
Einfach nur zu backuppen.
Das funktioniert teilweise und teilweise auch nicht.
Es gibt mittlerweile einen Fuse-Treiber, also einen File-System-Treiber für iPhones.
Ich muss teilweise rebooten dafür, dass es funktioniert.
Dann kannst du dann auf dein iPhone per USB angeschlossen zugreifen, auf fast alle Ordner, die drauf sind.
Aber schön ist es auch nicht.
Also...
Also, wenn du meinst, so Bilder runterziehen eignet sich's.
...Sign-On-Experience.
So, could I use Mac OS daily?
Yes, of course.
And I did in the past, back when I had a MacBook for work and my previous job before that.
I used Mac OS a ton.
And I liked that system.
But nowadays, after using GNOME and KDE for a long time,
I just don't really see any major advantages that I would absolutely want to use.
I think that our desktops nowadays are just better integrated, the features are more cleverly designed,
and sure, while we might lack a super polished App Store or all the breadth of applications that you might get on Mac OS,
I think we're still better.
And yes, I would rather use...
Ja, da ist es mit Android tatsächlich einfacher.
Chat, da habt ihr recht.
...but that's the conclusion you were probably expecting.
I just think our Linux desktops are better thought out.
What would also be very thought out...
Da kann man sich drüber streiten.
...would be to buy a computer with Linux pre-installed from today's...
Wait a minute!
Der hat zwei Sponsor im Video!
Alter!
Sponsor!
Eigenwerbung!
Okay, der hat das YouTube-Game durchgespielt, Alter.
Pog.
Danke für den Sub.
Pogge.
Oh, er ist Flex schon mal was von gehört.
Nein.
Ähm...
Ist der das gewesen?
Das kann der gewesen sein, ja.
Nee, der nicht Linux desktops...
Der hat Browser getestet und hat gesagt, er kann kein Firefox mehr verwenden,
und jetzt verwendet er wieder Firefox oder so.
Das könnte der Typ gewesen sein.
Genau.
Welche...
Äh, Manjaro, genau.
Ich hab...
Mein Setup auf der Arbeit ist mehr oder weniger das, was ich hier auch hab.
Sieht fast genauso aus.
Manjaro i3-WM.
Gzip-File-Compression in 100 Sekunden.
Nee.
Alter, ist mir jetzt alles zu lang.
Leute, in Anbetracht der Tatsache, dass wir heute Abend wahrscheinlich Battlefield spielen im Stream,
wenn...
das dann rauskommt,
und dass ich mal ganz dringend aufs Klo muss,
würde ich sagen, ich geh jetzt off,
und wir sehen uns später, falls ich Bock drauf hab.
Ich verspreche nichts, ja.
Aber, mal schauen.
Oh...
Nö, mit Manjaro ist alles gut.
Ist halt die Frage, ob du i3 willst.
Tiling Window Manager sind zum Einstieg nicht so der Wahnsinn.
Also Leute, wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut, bis denn.
See you.